or un autre
bonjour tout le monde je suis désolé
pour le retard mis à démarrer cette
affaire c'est simplement que je
travaille un peu trop con flux tendu et
c'est en train de regarder les questions
alors dans la première liste des choses
que j'ai vu il y avait tout un tas de
questions qui concernent le système
politique dans lequel on vit et juste
derrière la question de la convention
citoyenne je vais partir avec une
première question qui est est ce que le
système démocratique peut limiter le
réchauffement climatique sous les 1,25
voire sous les deux degrés alors je vais
commencer par répondre la première
partie de la première question qui est
que malheureusement limiter le
réchauffement sous les 1.5 go
c'est hélas déjà une affaire qui est
derrière nous il faut rappeler quelque
chose d'assez simple qui est que le
réchauffement nous aurons en 2100 dépend
de la totalité de ce qu'on va mettre
dans l'atmosphère d'ici à 2100 et la
totalité de ce qu'il faut mettre dans
l'atmosphère pour atteindre 1,5 degrés
en 2100 malheureusement on l'a déjà et
vit à la fin de l'année dernière donc
limitée sous 2100 sous 1,5 degré pardon
à ce stade ça n'est plus possible que
avec des scénarios qui retirerait du co2
de l'atmosphère à partir alors pas tout
à fait de maintenant mais on va dire que
ce qu'on aimait en plus par rapport à
maintenant doit être soustrait de
l'atmosphère avant la fin du 21e siècle
sinon on dépasse les arrivées le 5
devrait donc dit autrement en cela on
les a déjà perdu pour arriver à 2 degrés
il faut diviser les émissions par trois
d'ici à ce que mes enfants et mon âge
c'est à dire dans les 30 ans qui
viennent alors la question est est ce
qu'on arrive à imposer de façon douce ou
par imposer c'est ce qu'on arrive à
mettre en oeuvre de manière douce en
démocratie ce genre d'affaires
la réponse est assez simple la seule
possibilité d'y arriver c'est que ça
devienne un consensus qui dépasse
absolument tout le reste
dit autrement on a une petite chance
d'arriver à limiter le réchauffement
sous les deux degrés à partir du moment
où simultanément dans tous les pays de
la planète
on est capable dans les systèmes
politiques tels qu'ils sont y compris
dans les systèmes qui prône une
suprématie de la liberté individuelle
par rapport à tout le reste j'ai nommé
les états unis de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait un absolu consensus sur le fait que
les émissions baisse de 4% par an et que
tout le reste suit et ne ne cherche pas
à violer cette évite alors je vais dire
autrement ça veut dire que dans les
systèmes démocratiques
on est capable de dire à toutes les
entreprises
vos émissions vont baisser de 4% par an
et dans ce contexte là vous ferez le
chiffre d'affaires que vous faites ça
veut dire qu'on est capable de dire aux
individus aux émissions vont baisser de
4% par an et dans ce contexte là vous
aurez le pouvoir d'achat que vous aurez
et c'est donc c'est probablement que
malheureusement la réponse est bon du
coup je vais faire une petite digression
qui correspond à une question j'ai pas
vu dans la liste mais qu'on va déjà posé
récemment qui est est-ce qu'au fond un
système de type chinois n'est pas un bon
compromis en ce qui concerne le problème
que nous sommes en train de regarder et
il n'est pas complètement exclu que la
réponse soit oui
dit autrement il est évident que pour
lutter contre le changement climatique
dans les bon ordre de grandeur
il faut être capable de s'imposer des
efforts qui sont des efforts extrêmement
significatif et donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'on ait un pouvoir qu'ils soient
très forts pour être capable de faire
respecter ces efforts une fois que on a
décidé de les mettre en oeuvre ou une
fois que le pouvoir a décidé de les
mettre en oeuvre et il est assez peu
vraisemblable que on y arrive dans un
régime dans lequel toutes les quelques
années on est susceptible de remettre en
cause ce qui doit se faire et c'est
quand on regarde aujourd'hui où sont les
états qui ont des envies un peu
significatif sur la question je dis bien
un peu significatif sur la question
on va tomber sur des pays qui ont
historiquement un grand sens du
consensus parce que c'est des pays qui
étaient soit géographiquement très
contraint
typiquement les pays scandinaves où la
suisse qu'il fallait vite à ces leaders
soient des pays insulaires ce qui
revient à dire qu'ils sont très
contraint donc la grande bretagne est
une espèce d'union sacrée sur le carbone
dans une certaine limite parce que je ne
crois pas aujourd'hui qui soit par
exemple prêt à remettre en cause la
croissance au bénéfice de la baisse des
émissions mais c'est clair qu'il faut
qu' il ya des pays ça s'exerce dans des
pays dans lesquels il ya eu une
tradition historique de se serrer les
coudes et de faire des efforts
collectivement
quand cette tradition n'existe pas
encore une fois est typiquement les
états unis c'est très peu probable que
ça
du coup le corollaire de cette affaire
malheureusement il est que si la
situation se met à échapper à notre
contrôle
il n'est pas complètement certain et il
est malheureusement même assez certains
que la démocratie ne survivra pas donc
dans les risques évidents liés à la
solution involontaire au changement
climatique et à la contrainte
énergétique
moi j'y vois à l'évidence le risque que
la démocratie saute donc ce n'est pas
une très bonne et variable du coup la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est
est-ce que ça vaut le coup d'en faire
sauter un petit morceau à l'avance pour
que on évite d'en faire sauter
l'essentiel plus tard dans les systèmes
dans lesquels on en fait sauter un petit
morceau je signale qu'il y a notamment
ça va me permettre de faire le lien avec
la convention citoyenne les systèmes par
exemple de tirage au sort à partir du
moment où vous tirez les représentants
de la nation au sort du coup vous n'êtes
plus alors ça a des avantages et des
inconvénients j'ai pas regardé ce truc
en détail un mais il ya au moins un
inconvénient que vous n'avez plus vous
avez plus l'avantagent pardon de la
campagne électorale et du fait que vous
avez une forme de garantie que le
souhait de la majorité se retrouvera
dans les gens qui vont se retrouver aux
commandes
par contre vous éviter d'une certaine
manière le jeu partisan et le fait qu'
il ya une tentation de la démagogie au
moins au début il y alors ça ça va me
permettre donc de faire le lien avec la
convention citoyenne puisque on a 150
personnes tirées au sort qui arrive aux
affaires alors l'avantagent c'est que
vous avez des gens qui échappe au moins
au moment où ils arrivent à l'idée que
ils vont quand dira sacrifier au
contraire
par contre ça un gros inconvénient c'est
que les gens arrivent en ces temps pas
préparé puisqu'ils ont été tirés au sort
donc ils n'ont aucune idée de ce qui les
attendait et ça veut dire qu'il ya un
pouvoir très très fort qui appartient à
ce moment là aux gens qui vont les
informer de la situation qu'ils trouvent
en arrivant ce qui va sortir de la
convention citoyenne sera très très
fortement structurée par la capacité que
les gens qui participent à cette
convention
or on d'accéder à une information à peu
près correct est à peu près complète sur
les fêtes certain nombre d'entre vous
ont peut-être entendu il ya pas très
longtemps m'accrocher un tout petit peu
avec un journaliste de france culture à
qui j'ai essayé de faire remarquer qu'il
y avait une petite différence entre les
faits et les opinions alors je vais
revenir là dessus les faits c'est ce qui
peut être comment dire mis en évidence
par l'observation et qui ne peut pas
être contredit par un changement de
convention humaine exemple la terre est
ronde
c'est un fake on peut décider par
convention qu'elle est plate ça ne
change pas la forme de la terre la terre
se trouve à 150 millions de km du soleil
c'est un fait peu décidée par convention
qu'elle est derrière pluton ça ne
changera pas la position de la terre
donc les fesses et des choses sur
lesquelles il vaut mieux avoir les idées
claires parce que si on essaye de les
nier ou si on essaye d'en de l'es2 quand
ils ont pas d'avoir une perception
correcte de ces faits eh bien on a
toutes les chances d'aller dans le décor
en ce qui concerne la manière dont on va
gérer l'avenir et donc ne pas avoir de
débat inutile ou ne pas avoir de remise
en question des faits c'est quelque
chose qui est absolument essentiel pour
être capable d'aller de l'avant de façon
pertinente
à côté de ça il ya les opinions donc les
opinions c'est la terre est en ondes
doit-on l'explorer cl l'opinion on peut
dire que oui on peut dire que bon il ya
des tas de bons gars clément d'un côté
il ya les pas beaux arguments pour
l'autre autre exemple l'antarctique est
recouvert de glace ça c'est un fait
question est-ce que l'antarctique doit
être une terre international qui
n'appartient à aucun état ou est-ce que
ça va pas être le cas voilà ça ça relève
de l'opinion le fait de penser que oui
vous le fait de penser que non et bien
dans l'information initiale qui est
donné aux citoyens qui participent à la
convention citoyenne
là j'ai pas été vérifiés je n'ai pas
d'avis sur la question
mais c'est absolument évident qu'être
capable de leur donner les faits et une
quantité suffisante de fait pour qu'il
soit capable d'avoir eu une opinion
c'est un point qui est absolument
crucial j'avais déjà compris ça en 2003
parce que j'avais participé au comité de
pilotage d'une conférence de citoyens
sur le climat justement
et on avait retrouvé sans grande
surprise dans les conclusions des
citoyens une large partie de ceux qui
avaient été apportées aux citoyens en
question au moment de l'exposé initial
quand on leur avait dit voilà les faits
la deuxième chose en ce qui concerne
cette convention c'est que bien
évidemment il est très difficile pour
des gens qui découvrent le problème
d'avoir une idée claire sur tout les
imbrications que ça engendre une fois
qu'ils ont un peu compris et il est
évident qu'il ya un petit exercice de
manipulation
peut-être gros dans le fait que notre
cher président macro et 10 à la
convention ont trouvé mois des bonnes
idées pour baisser les émissions de 40%
si ma mémoire est bonne parce que toutes
les propositions qui pourront être
faites seront au mieux à l'état de meta
propositions par exemple si on dit il
faudrait que le fret routier concept de
forme en carburant une fois qu'on a dit
ça on n'a toujours pas dit si on taxe
monstrueusement le carburant authier en
attendant que les traits d'un françois
bloqué par les barrages jusqu'au moment
où les gens en ont marre de servir ou
bien aussi on électricité autoroute ou
bien si on vend deux fois moins de
marchandises dans ce pays
c'est deux fois moins transporté en ce
moment il ya toujours des transporteurs
routiers qui font faillite et donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'eux enfin voilà
il est absolument évident qu'une fois
qu'on est sorti de là l'objectif général
qu'il y sera très facile à énoncer le
diable sera dans les détails je ne suis
pas complètement persuadé on verra la
copie mais je ne suis pas complètement
cascades et que nos citoyens auront le
temps de faire comprendre tous les
tenants et les aboutissants de tout ce
qui se passe dans tous les domaines dans
lesquels ils vont faire une
recommandation la la portée de ce genre
de travail
les directions de choisi par don sont
très dépendantes de la formation
initiale et la portée de ce genre de
travail est très dépendante du temps que
les gens ont pour comprendre quelles
sont les implications des mesures qui ne
peuvent préconisé et c'est quelque chose
qui est un exercice difficile
donc pour en revenir à la question de la
démocratie est ce que la démocratie va y
arriver c'est pas sûr du reste on
constate que dans les temps anciens à
l'époque où le monde était très
contraint la démocratie était une
exception partiel à la règle qui voulait
que les régimes soit dirigée de façon
non libres non démocratique et que
l'exercice des libertés dépendent est
essentiellement de ce que la caste
dominante avait décidé de faire du temps
de la royauté ou la royauté c'est un
système dictatorial héréditaire un salut
rien d'autre le roi de droit divin donc
dans les systèmes anciens
il y avait des règles qui était dur et
l'exercice de la liberté individuelle
n'était pas du tout garanti à aucun
niveau et par ailleurs les conditions
n'évoluez pas au cours du temps
dans les temps anciens on essaie paysans
mourrez paysans il n'y avait pas
d'ascension sociale
l'ascenseur social c'est une création de
l'énergie ça l'ascension sociale ça
n'existait pas l'augmentation des
revenus avec l'âge ça n'existait pas non
plus pour l'essentiel des habitants donc
on essaie paysans avec les revenus qu'on
avait et on mourait paysans avec les
revenus qu'on avait sans retraite soit
dit en passant
donc le donc la question de savoir si
dans un univers qui redevient contre un
on est capable de préserver la
démocratie
à l'évidence une question essentielle et
quand on regarde les régimes qui sont
capables de se gérer de façon beaucoup
plus douce j'ai envie de dire avec tout
le monde qui papotent qui palabrent etc
on voit que c'est des régimes qui
s'applique souvent à des unités de
petite taille
la tribu et c'est souvent dans des
univers dans lesquels n'ya pas d'hiver a
passé des univers tropicaux et c'est la
nourriture est abondante toute l'année
pas de contrainte vraiment mais dans les
systèmes organisationnels à large
échelle qui sont apparus aux envoyés de
latitude
je ne connais pas beaucoup d'exceptions
au fait que en univers contraint la
démocratie n'existait pas une fois que
j'ai dit ça donc beaucoup plus avancé
pour savoir ce qu'on fait alors on peut
renverser le raisonnement après la
manière dont on peut renverser le
raisonnement c'est est ce qu'on n'a pas
intérêt à abdiquer de nous mêmes
quelques libertés qui ne sont pas
essentiels
histoire de préserver le plus longtemps
des libertés qui le sont beaucoup plus
qui nous sont extrêmement cher et c'est
clair qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
l'exercice de hiérarchisation ça ça
pourrait être un exercice intéressant a
mené un exercice de hiérarchisation de
nos libertés
dit autrement sinon doit n'en garder
qu'une c'est là qu'elle est ce que c'est
la diversité des blast se déplacer est
ce que c'est celle de s'exprimer et
c'est ce qu'est ce que c'est celle de
manger à sa faim voilà puis si après on
doit n'en garder qu'une deuxième
laquelle s etc
il est vraisemblable qu'un exercice de
cette nature aiderait énormément la
limite beaucoup plus que la convention
citoyenne qui a été fait
un exercice de hiérarchisation de
renoncement serait probablement un
exercice qui aiderait considérablement
le plus de pouvoir en place à savoir où
sont les choses sur lesquelles on est
prêt à faire des efforts que l'exercice
qui est fait de conventions ou
malheureusement encore une fois en
fonction de l'information initiale et
des et de la difficulté technique
d'implémentation s'est pas complètement
sûr que l'on va en sortir quelque chose
d' activable qui va résoudre tous les
problèmes qui se posent à nous et
notamment je suis pas du tout sûr que la
convention citoyenne préconisera s'il ya
un conflit d'objectif entre le pouvoir
d'achat et la baisse des émissions de
s'asseoir sur le pouvoir d'achat
pas complètement sûr que c'est ça qui
fera en sortie
alors après qu'est ce que j'ai dans ma
besace une fois que j'ai traité la
convention citoyenne
il y avait une question qui était posée
par exemple sur les impros de l'éolien
les autres le solaire etc
voilà typiquement à débat technique qui
n'est absolument pas la blue sea se dit
dans le cadre d'un panel de gens en
tirer au hasard sans qu'il passe par la
difficile et longue et aride étape de
s'imprégner des faits et de comprendre
quelles sont les caractéristiques
techniques de chacune de ses
possibilités
alors la question sur extinction et
bellion est ce que ça peut gagner assez
de poids politique va quelque part ça
s'inscrit dans ce que je viens de dire
c'est à dire que le la possibilité que
cette cette entité gagne du terrain et
finalement lié à la possibilité qu'elle
éclaire le pouvoir sur la hiérarchie de
noront lancement à partir du moment où
800 tr bellion est clair le pouvoir sur
la hiérarchie des renoncements possible
pour une large partie de la population
oui ça fera oeuvre utile c'est
absolument évident si c'est juste je
suis contre tous malheureusement on
retombe dans quelque chose qui est une
mouvance historique qui n'aide pas
beaucoup parce que si on est contre tout
on n'est pas le gouvernement à choisir
on n'a pas le pouvoir choisir
or gérer c est choisir ses tranchées et
ses arbitres et c'est dire je les
accepte ça en contrepartie de ça donc
c'est on en revient à 7 est donc exclue
rébellion sera utile si l'aide à haïr
archi zélés des renoncements
alors après petites questions sur vos
mains
e
[Musique]
ah oui après il y avait une question sur
l'échelon local qui est dans cette
histoire qu'est ce qu'on peut faire à
l'échelon allègement du territoire alors
il ya un projet qui va être lancée par
le chic project dans ces serments
soutenu qui consiste justement à essayer
de répondre à cette question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire au niveau des
territoires
le projet en question il va s'appeler
résilience des territoires et donc son
objectif va être d'outils et les élus
locaux pour qu'ils comprennent
1 quelles sont les contraintes qui les
attendent donc en gros le panorama
énergétique vue d'une collectivité
locale qu'est ce qu'ils signifient
qu'est ce qu'il implique
qu'est-ce qu'il peut créer comme
difficulté à l'avenir ou comme
opportunité et le panorama climatique
qu'est-ce que il implique comme
difficultés parce que là malheureusement
c'est surtout des difficultés à venir
pour un élu local et une fois qu'on
croise les deux la question ça va être
quels sont tous les sujets tous les
défis tous les points de vigilance et
avec évidemment un certain nombre de
suggestions qui peuvent être faites sur
la manière de commencer à s'y attaquer
donc c'est sale c'est ça le sujet qu'on
va attaquer au chic project donc la
réponse à la question et bien rendez
vous dans un an je sais que ces longues
on n'a pas beaucoup de fois un an
puisque nous avons très exactement
trente fois un an pour diviser les
émissions planétaires par 3 mai
rendez-vous dans un an
parce que on a l'intention de s'attaquer
à la question en espérant que l'on y
sera un tout petit peu utile là alors
après il ya une question sur la
décroissance et si j'ai bien compris
votre analyse
la décroissance est inévitable la
réponse est oui un tout petit peu
quelles sont les activités salariées ou
pas qui pourrait permettre au plus grand
nombre de subsister alors c'est ya un
raisonnement au premier ordre que je
fais souvent dans ce domaine qui est de
dire que probablement que la
décroissance va engendrer des processus
qui sont pas très loin d'être
l'évolution inverse de ce qu'on a
constatée sur les deux derniers siècles
si on reprend l'histoire la croissance
est quelque chose qui a commencé à
devenir significative quand les hommes
ont commencé à s'adjoindre les services
de machines alors il ya eu une petite
poussée au moyen-âge selon mon ami
michel le petit en france et puis
ensuite c'est l'angle de la grande
bretagne qui démarre la première la
civilisation industrielle qui la
première connaît la croissance alors la
croissance et l'adjonction des machines
engendre 3 et fera quelques effets par
contre est significatif sur
l'organisation de la vie et de tout le
monde tout le monde ça change la
structure des métiers et en particulier
ça déplace d'emploi de manière massive
de l'agriculture vers l'industrie et les
services
les services sont comme d'industrie
dépendant de l'énergie abondante
parce que ses services n'existent pas
sans flux industriels sous jacent le
look ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que ça déplace
l'occupation du territoire il y à un
question qui m'a été posée là sur la
taille optimale des villes alors les
gens dans les villes je viens va
préparer donc
donc non je vais le faire tout de suite
donc les maîtres donc ça favorise les
métiers qui sont industriels et de
service et ça favorise par ailleurs les
métiers urbain
c'est à dire que ça met ensemble des
gens qui doivent travailler ensemble
alors dans l'industrie les gens doivent
travailler ensemble on doit mettre
ensemble toutes les personnes qui
travaillent dans la même usine plus
l'énergie est abondante et plus on a une
organisation qui permet d'assurer des
transports facile et à ce moment plus on
va avoir des usines qui sont de taille
importante et spécialisée sur une seule
tâche
dit autrement la une ford avait mis des
ouvriers spécialisés sur une seule tâche
dans des usines qui faisaient tous deux
1 jusqu'à z
donc on veut ça me faisait la totalité
d'une voiture dans une usine en eau
par contre chaque ouvrier lui il avis
c'est qu'un seul bull on est bien on a
créé aujourd'hui une théorisation des
usines et non pas des emplois donc vous
avez des usines qui ne font que des semi
conducteurs après des usines qui ne font
que des cartes mères après des usines
qui ne font que des écrans d'ordinateur
des usines qui et c'est donc on a
terrorisé les usines et non pas dans les
camions on ne fait que la portière du
camion un endroit puis un autre endroit
on ne fait que la peindre puis un
troisième endroit que l'assemblée sur la
cabine du camion
on a on a théorisé les usines avec au
sein de chaque usine par contre des
tâches qui peuvent être extrêmement
variés et on a relié tout ça par des
transports qui coûtent pas cher plus on
terrorise les usines plus on les
spécialistes plus on les fait grossir et
plus évidemment on a besoin de gens
concentré au même endroit pour les
services c'est exactement pareil alors
les services sont par ailleurs des
métiers des changes et échanger c'est
facile quand les gens sont entassés les
uns sur les autres
soit dit en passant c'est pour ça qu'on
a créé les villes c'est pour gérer les
échanges et vous constaterez que les
villes constate consiste parlant
historiquement à entasser les villes et
les villages qui sont aussi des lieux
des champs plus petits à entasser les
gens les uns sur les autres
donc à faire des maisons qui sont
adjacentes en l'air plus quelque chose
r plus 3 + 4/5 passer les uns contre les
autres et mis en disque autour des lieux
des changes
donc en cercle parce que c'est comme ça
que la distance au lieu des changes et
la moindre pour l'ensemble des gens qui
y habitent et les lieux des changes sont
au centre de la ville partout donc
l'église où on échange les valeurs
morales la place de marché où on échange
des biens l'école où on échange des
savoirs la présentation du croire
on échange des règles de vie en commun
tout ça est au centre donc si l'énergie
devient contrainte
globalement on détricote le système
alors on détricote le système
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que vous
avez moins de transport facile qui
assure les maillon intermédiaire de tout
ce système ça veut dire la
démondialisation ça veut dire la
déspécialisation des unités productives
et donc logiquement que tout se met à
coûter plus cher
y compris les panneaux solaires et les
éoliennes j'ai regardé ça veut dire le
la fin d'emploi urbain qui occupe
l'essentiel de la population la
population se remet à habiter près de là
où l'on trouve la ressource et on la
travaille alors le tout petit sujet dans
cette affaire c'est que il n'est pas
complètement sûr qu'on puisse remettre
au chant une population qui fait
aujourd'hui d'une milliards d'individus
donc la contraction énergétique sera
d'autant plus facile à gérer et c'est
évidemment quelque chose de très
douloureux que de se dire ça que la
taille de la population n'aura pas trop
augmenter dans les pays occidentaux ce
cas on a aujourd'hui en france par
exemple vous avez aujourd'hui moins d'un
hectare par habitant surface
métropolitaine on à 55 millions
d'hectares et il ya 65 millions
d'habitants
ça veut dire que pour recréer un système
essentiellement agricole c'est pas
simple voilà donc le les métiers qui
résistent
j'ai envie de dire la contraction
énergétiques sont des métiers qui vont
progressivement vers la polyvalence le
fait de sortir progressivement de la
ville c'est à leur vie dit comme ça et
c'est des métiers qui vont vers une
forme de résilience au sens large c'est
aussi des métiers qui s'occupe de gérer
les communautés est-ce qu'on fait rien
tout seul
il ya un grand mythe survivalistes sur
le fait que l'on peut face à ce problème
là tous enterrés dans sa cave
et avec son fusil et 40 tonnes de boîtes
de conserve personnellement j'y crois
pas trop
le lead sur les badistes américain je
crois beaucoup plus au fait que dans ce
genre de système la coopération va être
essentiel du reste on le voit bien par
exemple dans la france pendant
l'occupation l'essentiel des gens quand
même était plutôt sur un mode coopératif
que sur un mode jetable sûrement voisins
donc quand les temps sont durs il faut
coopérer
il faut faire des systèmes qui sont plus
collectif et qui soit dit en passant
pour en revenir au début de cet échange
conduisent aussi quelque part abdiqué
délibérément une partie de sa liberté
individuelle
[Musique]
comment est ce qu'on a sur ce genre de
transition
alors on l'a sûr j'ai envie d en deux
temps il ya un premier sujet qui est de
ne pas en rajouter par rapport aux
problèmes existants et donc je fais
partie des gens et ça va nous ramener à
la taille des villes
je fais partie des gens qui aujourd'hui
considèrent que de continuer à faire
grossir les mégapoles est une mauvaise
idée
je vais expliquer pourquoi dans pas
longtemps ça veut aussi dire que dans ce
contexte là il ne faut pas avoir un
système éducatif qui prépare tout le
monde a un emploi de bureau
or aujourd'hui depuis mitterrand et sans
droits d'accès à l'université pour tous
on a entretenu l'idée qu' il était
légitime dans le pays que tout un chacun
puisse faire des études supérieures et
donc sous-entendu derrière accéder à un
emploi de bureau
alors ça c'est quelque chose qui marche
très bien dans un monde de machines dans
un monde de machines
effectivement on peut tous avoir accès à
un emploi de bureau puisque les machines
travaillent pour nous et à ce moment
notre seul travail à nous consiste à
gérer ces machines et à gérer le flux
que c'est la chine créé et donc on peut
tous avoir des emplois tertiaires enfin
à défaut d'être des ancres bureau des
entrées tertiaire encore que une bonne
partie des emplois tertiaires sans match
il vise à bhl aux boat is able par
exemple un vendeur ou une vendeuse chez
h&m est parfaitement remplaçable par une
machine c'est à dire un site en ligne et
derrière des entrepôts robotisée qui
vous envoie les trucs par drones
robotisée tous à localiser par gps et
aucun problème parce qu'il n'est plus
très loin
il ya un ya aucun problème pour
remplacer tout ça tout ça par des
machines et nous on se contente de
donner des ordres aux machines alors ça
ça marche très bien dans un système à
l'énergie abondante dans un système à
l'énergie abondante toutes les machines
travaillent pour nous les tracteurs aux
drones en passant par les camions et les
laminoirs et nous ont juste là à leur
donner des ordres
assis dans un bureau dans un monde où il
ya moins de machines ça marche pas bien
donc ça veut dire que il faut qu'on se
prépare à l'idée qu'il y aura moins
d'emplois qui seront des emplois de
bureau ou des emplois que que bureau
j'ai envie de dire
peut-être qu'on va voir apparaître des
systèmes de gens qui auront deux
activités je cultive mon potager le
matin je suis au bureau l'après midi ou
ce soir hier a fallu qu'elle de cette
nature il ya un sujet donc sur les
villes et en fait la partie la plus
fragile des villes c'est les couronnes
périurbaines
parce que c'est là que les gens sont le
plus à la marge de la fonction des
changes de la ville d'abord ils sont
plus loin du centre ils ont besoin de
plus d'énergie pour assurer les
fonctions des changes se déplacer aller
au travail etc
c'est aussi des gens qui sont le moins
indispensable parce que s'ils sont là
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas beaucoup de
moyens
et s'ils n'ont pas beaucoup de moyens
c'est qu'ils sont pas pré qualifiés
qu'est ce qu'il faut pas très qualifiés
c'est que c'est les premiers à sauter
dans un univers plus contraints et sur
les villes il ya donc une évolution à
rebours quelque part aussi qui est à
réfléchir parce quand on voit à quoi
ressemblaient les villes il ya quelques
siècles est bien évident il ya quelques
siècles il n'y avait pas de banlieue il
y avait une ville très dense qui était
ceint de murailles soit dit en passant
la pac avec une frontière extrêmement
franche entre la ville et la campagne
et c'était ça qui à cette époque là
correspondait à la fonction optimum de
la ville qui était de gérer des échanges
et gérer des échanges quand on était un
peu loin du centre il n'y arrivait pas
alors pourquoi est ce que les villes
était petit et très dense
il ya longtemps elle était très dense
pour assurer les fonctions des changes à
l'intérieur et elle était petite parce
que la première nécessité dans une ville
c'est que les habitants puissent se
nourrir
ce qui veut dire que à l'époque où les
aliments n'était pas conservable
longtemps donc il y avait pas de chaîne
du froid il n'y avait pas de transport
frigorifique
il n'y avait pas de boîtes de conserve
et y'avait pas etc on peut dire qu en
première approximation
la taille maximale d'une ville était
conditionnée par la distance qu'on
arrivait à parcourir à pied ou
éventuellement en charrette à boeufs en
un ou deux jours c'est à dire le temps
que les aliments se périment donc une
ville puisque par exemple il ya un ou
deux pardon il ya quelques siècles quand
il y avait pas de celle du froid la
viande
vous étiez capable de transporter
l'animal une fois abattue à mon avis sur
un jour de trajet et puis pas beaucoup
plus
après ça ça variait surtout en été donc
le la ville était conditionnée par la
distance peut on pouvait pourquoi
parcourir en 1/2 allait enfin quelques
jours de marche ce qui veut dire que la
quantité d'habitants qu'on pouvait y
trouver et est délimitée par le surplus
agricoles qui étaient capables de
fournir le disque située à
allez on va dire deux jours de marche ou
de charette du centre donc je reprends
l'explication
les gens qui font l'agriculture dans ce
disque situé à deux jours de marche du
centre
évidemment il faut qu'ils commencent par
se nourrir eux donc la taille de la
ville
elles étaient conditionnées parce que
ces gens là étaient capables de fournir
comme nourriture en plus de ce dont ils
avaient besoin de se nourrir eux mêmes
points de son désir avait besoin
d'argent pour se nourrir eux-mêmes et
qu'ils étaient capables d'exporter vers
la ville où il n'y avait pas d'activité
agricole c'est pour ça que lutèce compte
à l'époque gauloise dix mille habitants
des stores là c'est pour ça que jusqu'au
haut moyen-âge 1500 paris compte dix
mille feux c'est à dire en gros quelques
dizaines de milliers d'habitants c'est
pour ça que paris en 1800 ne compte
toujours que cinq cent mille personnes
alors là par contre vous commencez à
avoir des charrettes
vous commencez à avoir de l'industrie
des concerts
vous commencez à avoir du train etc donc
on est déjà beaucoup mieux outillés et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut absolument les
moyens de transport modernes pour être
capable de faire vivre une mégapole de
10 millions d'habitants ce qui je prends
l'île de france comme mégapoles et c'est
une autre manière de dire que dans un
monde à l'énergie très contrainte
eh bien il est totalement insoutenables
de garder des villes de cette taille
donc on va avoir un vrai sujet
d'aménagement du territoire et qui est
de faire retourner des villes à utah qui
soit compatible avec un
approvisionnement qui sera beaucoup plus
contraints et donc beaucoup plus local
aujourd'hui le rayon d'approvisionnement
d'une ville comme paris c'est la terre
entière
les avocats ville du pérou les litchis
de madagascar les haricots verts du
maroc
les oranje de tunisie les tomates en
cette saison j'ai pas d'où elles
viennent pour le monde serre nantaise ou
du maroc aussi du reste le soja pour
nourrir nos animaux vient de l'amérique
du sud ou du milieu des tats-unis
ailleurs la chaîne alimentaire qui
permet aux parisiens de manger comme il
mange aujourd'hui est une chaîne
mondiale mondiale donc il n'y a pas du
tout la possibilité aujourd'hui de faire
quoi que ce soit de local de façon un
peu sérieuse dans une ville de quelques
millions d'habitants c'est juste
totalement impossible si les
informations sont exactes je crois que
la couronne maraîchère de l'île de
france elle est capable
le pardon l'île de france est capable de
fournir je pourrais faire le calcul du
reste quelques pourcents de ce que mange
aujourd'hui des franciliens donc c'est
la survie de l'île de france et je
pourrais dire la même chose de lyon je
pourrais dire la même chose de marseille
je pourrais dire la même chose de
bordeaux je crois car une chose de
grenoble n'est possible que grâce aux
camions aux bateaux et aux avions
supprimer de pétrole demain matin les
parisiens meurent de faim vraiment comme
ça qu'il faut voir le qu'il faut voir le
sujet donc le donc les métiers qui
survivent dans un monde de contraction
énergétique
ne sont pas aussi c'est là que je
voulais en venir par construction des
métiers qui s'exerce dans une ville de
10 millions d'habitants
il y en a beaucoup qui malheureusement
ne passeront pas leur rentrer ça
s'organise ce genre de choses et pour
renvoyer également à la première partie
de cette discussion
il est évident que on ne gérera pas le
transfert d'une partie de la population
des villes vers des villages ou des
petites villes où la campagne sans une
politique d'aménagement du territoire
qui soit une politique un peu dirigiste
c'est absolument évident qu'il est
nécessaire d'avoir quelque chose d'un
peu structurée pour y arriver est par
exemple on peut se poser la question et
ça renvoie la question des collectivités
locales
si dans ce genre de contexte on y arrive
en laissant permettant ce et robert
s'est pas complètement sûr que tant que
chacun décide de sa politique
d'urbanisme à son niveau
eh bien on est un schéma cohérent à
l'échelle du territoire c'est même
raisonnablement sûr que c'est l'inversé
alors pour autant il suffit pas de
donner permis construire au préfet pour
qu'il en fasse à bas du visage presque
tant que l'état ne demandent pas d'en
faire un bon usage le préfet enfin le
même visage que l'état lui demande c'est
à dire potentiellement n'importe quoi
donc ce n'est pas une condition
suffisante de retirer le permis quand tu
robert par contre dans une politique un
peu volontariste d'aménagement du
territoire pour augmenter la résilience
face aux contraintes à venir s'est pas
complètement sûr on puisse le laisser
ouvert il ya un autre sujet évidemment
qui vient se greffer à sac et celui de
la croissance démographique
il est bien évident qu'à partir du
moment où la superficie du pays et fils
inc
plus on est nombreux dessus plus ça sera
difficile de faire sortir des gens de
villes pour les mettre à la campagne
donc on a aussi un sujet à ce niveau là
sur lequel j'ai pas de solution trivial
a proposé tout de suite
par contre j'ai un sujet évident à
mettre sur la table c'est qu'il faut en
discuter
aujourd'hui ça fait quand même partie
des sujets qui sont dans l'écran angles
morts des débats une des raisons soit
dit en passant pour lequel c'est
probablement dans les angles morts des
débats c'est qu'on se dit il n'y a pas
de raison que la civilisation urbaine ne
dure pas c'est le sien c'est un combat
c'est un sujet qui vient très fortement
des économistes cette histoire comme les
économistes pensent que le pib va
augmenter pour l'éternité et que par
ailleurs plus on est nombreux et plus ça
permet au pib d'augmenter et qu'une fois
que le pib a augmenté on a tous à manger
et tout ce qu'il faut
il n'y a pas de raison d'empêcher la
population augmente et tout ça est très
bon
c'est un raisonnement que le physicien
peu l'agronome ou que n'importe quel
ingénieur du monde philippe pourra
trouver un peu curieux mais en attendant
c'est un raisonnement qui est très très
souvent tenus par des économistes
et comme c'est eux qui tiennent le haut
du pavé en ce qui concerne la façon de
voir l'avenir
eh bien on a ainsi un petit sujet sur 7
sur cette démographie qui est considéré
comme étant un non sujet pour la
répétition alors que personnellement je
pense que c'en est un alors maintenant
[Musique]
petite question complémentaire sur la
collecte solide jsk un effondrement
brutal est probable alors la réponse
c'est que je n'en sais rien la la
ce qui est en train de se passer en ce
moment il faut le voir comme un exercice
de tectonique des plaques
la tectonique des plaques c'est vous
mettez le système en tension et puis de
temps en temps il fait des craquements
alors la tectonique des plaques peut
s'appliquer de plusieurs manières c'est
à dire qu'il peut y avoir un seul
tremblement de terre qui vous fiche
totalement par terre par exemple les
californiens redoute big one celui qui
fera craquer chez troc elle file à de
san andreas et qui risque de mettre la
ville totalement sans dessus dessous en
une seule fois
et puis il ya des tremblements de terre
qui peuvent arriver de manière régulière
et à ce moment ils sont pas trop violent
parce que l'énergie de la mise en
tension se libère à intervalles
réguliers
je n'ai aucune idée de la façon dont ça
va se passer en ce qui concerne la
descente énergétique de notre
civilisation il
pour espérer soit dit en passant que ça
se fasse plus tôt par des soulagements
périodique de la tension par des petits
traitement mais répétés plutôt que par
un gros gros craquement qui fera très
très mal encore que les dés qu'ils
lisent une grande purge et après ça va
mieux c'était s'est-elle c'était le même
comment dire c'était une bonne guerre
nous fera du bien
moi je le prends très pressé d'avoir une
bannière
par contre c'est évident qu'il va y
avoir des craquements dans le système et
donc il faut quelque part espéré qu'il
arrive le plus tôt possible de la façon
la plus régulière possible de la plus
con tinue possible et il faut également
espérer ça c'est quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas du tout donné que
par delà la communauté des initiés quand
les craquements arrivent ils soient
compris pour ceux qui sont si gentils
j'en juge par ce que je vois par exemple
encore aujourd'hui sur la compréhension
de la grande crise qu'il ya eu en 2008
très très peu de gens autour de moi
attribue cette crise aux problèmes qu'il
ya eu sur le pétrole à partir de 2005
très très peu donc temps que
l'attribution des causes n'est pas
comprise ça c'est également un vrai
problème
à ce moment la cause ne peut pas être
traité puisque on pense que le problème
vient d'ailleurs
donc tant qu'on pense que la seule
raison de la crise financière de 2008
c'est que les banquiers ont fait
n'importe quoi et qu'il suffit de
renforcer la législation bancaire pour
éviter le retour du problème est bien la
seule chose dont on est absolument
certain c'est que le problème relié à
l'europe puisque le problème ne vient
pas de là comme le dit très bien les
associer tout ce qu'on est en train de
faire c'est de renforcer la tuyauterie
mais comme ça va recommencer à prêter de
toute façon où s'arrêtera la prochaine
fois ça sera encore plus loin c'est
exactement ce la manière dont il faut
voir le second qu'il faut voir
l'attribution des causes est un trip
très important et c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles je continue à passer
beaucoup de temps à essayer d'attirer
l'attention sur le fait que les sujets
énergie et climat peuvent avoir des
conséquences dans le monde économique et
peuvent avoir des conséquences dans le
monde physique dès maintenant c'est
parce que j'espère contribuer à une
meilleure compréhension de l'attribution
des causes
sans laquelle encore une fois on tire au
jugé en ce qui concerne les solutions et
ça peut faire très très mal de tiré au
jugé ça peut très fortement aggravé le
problème
plutôt que de contribuer à leu leu leu
soulager démographie et bien j'en ai
parlé tout à l'heure à tient une petite
question complémentaire
est-ce qu'on a une idée assez précise du
niveau de vie par habitant maximum qu'un
monde renouvelables peut supporter pour
sept milliards d'individus
et bien la réponse j'en sais rien quand
le monde était totalement renouvelable
il comportait plus de 500 millions
d'individus donc au monde totalement
renouvelable peut arriver de 7 milliards
d'individus s'est pas complètement sûr
on a eu un exposé par exemple d'un
chercheur aux ateliers du chiffre il n'y
a pas très longtemps pedro chelsea
pyros donc allé voir dans la vie des
vidéos passent résolution évidemment
j'espère que reste que vous m'avez mis
en basse résolution voir que vous avez
complètement supprimée de vos écrans
puisque mon ma trombine ne sert à rien
dans cette histoire donc qui a expliqué
que dans un monde dans lequel il y
aurait plus d'énergie fossile
l'agriculture ne serait à peine capable
de nourrir les hommes et pas avec autant
d'animaux qu'aujourd'hui et qu'elle ne
pourrait pas amener un surplus d'énergie
significatif à la société donc c'est pas
sûr qu'on puisse avoir sept milliards
d'habitants avec pas d'énergie fossile
du tout voilà ce qui soit dit en passant
nous amènera tout à l'heure au sujet de
lui le favori enfin que j'ai favori de
monsieur guillaume erner à savoir le
nucléaire il est la raison pour laquelle
je vois ça justement comme un parachute
centrale c'est-à-dire le fait que de ne
pas en faire alourdira encore le fardeau
par rapport au fait d' enfer dans les
limites de ce qu'on arrivera à faire
dans le monde qui se prépare et je
répondrai à toutes les questions parce
que j'ai vu qu'un avait plein de
questions intéressantes sur escaut un
système nucléaire survie dans un monde
chaotique parce qu'évidemment c'est une
question intéressante
alors maintenant nous allons parler du
prix du pétrole
je vois que il ya un certain nombre de
gens qui me disent comment se fait-il
qu'il y ait une pénurie sur le prix du
pétrole une pénurie sur le pétrole
puisque le prix du pétrole n'augmentent
pas et si je vais à la pompe j'ai du
pétrole
alors je vais commencer par faire un
tout petit aveu d'humilité je n'ai moi
même pas compris tout encore dans cette
histoire c'est à dire qu'il ya un
certain nombre de faits que je vais
exposer maintenant j'ai compris qu'ils
étaient là je comprends le raisonnement
dans son ensemble il vaut mieux puisque
je vais vous l'exposer par contre j'ai
pas encore analysé en détail tous les
ressorts économiques qui font que ça se
passe comme ça et c'est un des sujets
que j'aimerais beaucoup voir traitée
dans le monde économique
c'est justement la réponse à cette
question qui est comment expliquer que
comment s'applique économiquement plus
exactement une restriction sur le
pétrole dont je vais vous expliquer dans
les grandes lignes
mais je pense que ça mériterait des
travaux économiques complémentaires de
la part d'économistes qui voudraient
bien s'intéresser à ce sujet pas
complètement inintéressant lorsque j'ai
discuté avec l'illustrent dennis meadows
il ya quelques années quand il était
venu en france pour l'édition française
de fortigate de dali mr wolf dont
j'avais rédigé la préface à l'époque et
toujours disponible en ligne sur mon
site soit dit en passant on avait parlé
exactement de ce sujet et des dix
meadows m'avait dit à l'époque ce qui
fait la rareté ce qui matérialise la
rareté d'une ressource dans le modèle
world 3 ça n'est pas du tout que son
prix s'envolent du reste avait pas de
prix dans le modèle c'est le fait que le
capital qu'on doit allouer à
l'extraction additionnel de cette
ressource augmente indéfiniment
c'est comme ça que ce
et réalise la rareté dit autrement la
manière dont se matérialise la rareté
sur la disponibilité croissante sur la
disponibilité du pétrole se matérialise
par deux paramètres qui n'ont rien à
voir avec le prix le premier c'est que
les investissements qu'il faut consentir
c'est à dire la quantité de fer la
quantité de gens qu'il faut faire
travailler la quantité de béton et c'est
qu'il faut consentir pour extraire un
baril jour supplémentaire augmente de
façon indéfinie et une des manières dont
ça se matérialise aujourd'hui c'est que
les investissements qu'il faut consentir
pour extraire un baril par jour dans ce
qu'on appelle le pétrole de schiste chez
lloyd qui en français s'appelle
normalement le pétrole de roche mère
tout ça c'est les mêmes appels nationaux
c'est la même chose eh bien les
investissements qu'il faut consentir de
son secteur là sont très supérieurs aux
investissements qu'il faut consentir
dans le pétrole dits traditionnels
c'est à dire le pétrole à terre ou le
pétrole offshore même et c'est à cause
de ça soit dit en passant que les
exploitants de pétrole de schiste ne
gagnait pas d'argent parce qu'ils
vendent le baril au même prix que tout
le monde parce qu'il ya un prix mondial
pour le baril par contre ils ont besoin
de mettre beaucoup plus d'investissement
sur la table pour y arriver et donc
et en plus ces investissements ils ont
le besoin de les faire avec de l'argent
qu'on leur a prêtés à des taux d'intérêt
assez élevé et donc quand on met
boutabout le fait qu'ils doivent payer
ses investissements et en plus payer les
investisseurs avec des taux d'intérêt
assez élevé et d'un il n'y arrive pas et
ils gagnent ou perdent de l'argent sur
le pétrole qu'ils vendent donc le shale
oil est une entreprise de vente à perte
depuis le début parce que les besoins en
capital sont beaucoup plus élevés pour
extraire un baril par jour dans les
sables bitumineux les besoins en capital
sont aussi beaucoup plus élevé je
connais pas l'équation économique de ces
gens là soit dit en passant j'ai jamais
regarder en détail ce que je sais c'est
que le patron d'un groupe pétrolier
m'avait dit que en dessous de 80 ou 100
dollars le baril perdaient de l'argent
c'est dans ces univers là alors une fois
que les investissements sont payé
probablement pas je sais pas que
l'équation des gens qui sont dedans
aujourd'hui mais par contre pour des
nouveaux projets c'est sûr que non
et donc l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles total a remis sur étagère ses
projets dans le domaine
c'est entre autres parce que de toute
façon il n'aurait pas gagné d'argent en
acceptant à 50 dollars le baril donc ça
c'est la première la première chose à
surveiller c'est ça et la deuxième chose
à surveiller c'est que le rendement
intrinsèque de cette extraction dix
minutes le fameux euroise energy return
en énergie il reste aide
dit autrement on a besoin de dépenser de
plus en plus de joules pour faire sortir
des geôles de la croûte terrestre
c'est ça le deuxième indicateur de la
rareté progressive et à ce jeu là le
shale oil et les sables bitumineux sont
également emblématique de la difficulté
croissante à se procurer du pétrole
puisque dans un cas comme dans l'autre
il faut en gros consacrer un quart de
l'énergie extraite au processus
d'extraction de l'énergie alors que dans
les grands gisements à terre avec
lesquels on a des tons a démarré j'ai
envie de dire les rênes du pétrole on
était plutôt aux alentours de 1%
dit autrement il fallait ex consacrer 1
% de l'énergie extraite à l'extraction
de cette énergie
donc les deux indicateurs de la rareté
progressive du pétrole et quand on les
regarde
ils sont bien en train de s'appliquer
c'est d'une part l'augmentation des
besoins en capital pour extraire un
débit données et d'autre part la baisse
du rendement énergétique intrinsèque de
cette extraction
ni l'un ni l'autre n'ont quoi que ce
soit à voir avec le prix de marché qui
résulte d'un équilibre du mouvement
entre la quantité de pétrole qu'on a à
offrir et la quantité de pétrole que les
gens souhaitent consommer ou ont besoin
de consommer donc ce n'est pas tellement
le conte besoin le préfère le souhaite
parce que l'essentiel de notre
consommation c'est pas des besoins et
des désirs soldats personnellement je
n'ai pas besoin du rer pour aller à
paris
j'habite à 20 km de paris et donc s'il
ya plus de herbert je vous laisse trois
heures plus tôt le matin j'y vais à pied
voilà donc ce que je peux encore aller à
paris je n'ai pas besoin entre
guillemets du erreur par contre c'est un
désir solvable j'ai les moyens de me
payer je trouve ça très bien
donc pour en revenir au pétrole il n'y a
pas le prix dans les indicateurs de
rareté et du reste quand vous regardez
historiquement comment a évolué le prix
du pétrole en fonction de la quantité
qu'on pouvait acheter sur le marché
on ne voit rien qui ressemble à une
élasticité prix volume dit autrement il
ya aucune règle qui dit s'il y en a
moins
s'il y en a de moins en moins c'est de
plus en plus cher et s'il y en a de plus
en plus c'est de moins en moins cher
c'est pas du tout comme ça que ça marche
il peut y avoir des chocs transitoire
évidemment serre si à un moment il avait
toujours la même quantité puis tout d'un
coup paf y en a moins à ce moment le
prix monte mais c'est transitoire
derrière il peut se passer n'importe
quoi alors en fait la raison un stade
est la suivante c'est que le pétrole est
un facteur limitant de l'économie
planétaire parce que le pétrole permet
d'alimenter des transports si vous avez
moins de pétrole vous avez moins de
transport physiquement disponible donc
la question est comment est-ce que
économiquement
le système se comportent et c'est ça la
question à laquelle j'ai pas la réponse
pour le moment de façon film donc c'est
ça donc je disais ça serait intéressant
de mettre des économistes là dessus pour
qu'il nous donne la réponse
par contre ce que je sais c'est que si
les transports consomme ce qui se trouve
sur une console si vous avez tout d'un
coup moins de pétrole vous aurez moins
de transport ça c'est physique
inexorable et comme on est dans ce monde
de grandes industries taylorisés qui
communique enfin de ceux de ce grand
industrie par don spécialisés qui
communiquent les unes avec les autres et
de bassins de consommation qui eux mêmes
sont desservis par les transports
à partir du moment où vous avez moins de
transports disponibles et bien le
système productif se contracte il est
plus capable d'assurer de bout en bout
la production et la livraison est donc
le pib baisse à partir du moment où le
pib baisse comme par la magie de la
comptabilité nationale le pib c'est la
somme des revenus
c'est la somme de la production mais
c'est aussi la somme des revenus si on
produit moins on a moins de revenus
si on a moins de revenus à ce moment les
gens au moins de quoi s'acheter de tout
y compris du pétrole mais aussi y
compris des voitures donc il ya un
certain nombre de gens quand le pib
baisse qui ne vont plus roulé en voiture
parce que ils ont plus les moyens
d'assurer la voiture parce qu'ils ont
plus les moyens d'en acheter une alors
que le voiture tombe en panne parce que
dieu vous ne sais pas quoi
parce que ils déménagent pour aller se
mettre dans un endroit où ils n'ont pas
besoin de voiture et donc à partir du
moment où ils la font moins roulé et
donc à partir du moment où la demande va
baisser parce que les gens ont moins
d'argent
eh bien vous retombez sur un nouveau
prix d'équilibré et ceux qui ont encore
les moyens de rouler en voiture qui sont
donc ceux qui vont poser la question en
disant quand je vais à la pompe
j'ai toujours de quoi m'en acheter oui
ceux-là ont toujours les moyens parce
que le pétrole a trouvé un nouveau prix
d'équilibré qui n'est pas nécessairement
beaucoup plus haut où beaucoup plus bas
que celui qu'il avait avant
donc ceux qui ont toujours les moyens de
rouler en voiture constate que après une
période de chocs
le prix du pétrole et le prix de
l'essence à la pompe il est toujours
abordable mais en fait c'est oublier que
dans cette affaire il ya une partie de
la population qui elle a un problème
croissant avec le prix du carburant et
si elles continuent à s'approvisionner
en carburant alors les objets de se
restreindre sur autre chose c'est
notamment la revendication des gilet
jaune au moment où ils sont descendus
dans la rue vous avez des besoins de
transport obligatoire en milieu rural et
à ce moment ils sont donc la raison pour
laquelle on ne voit pas le prix à la
pompe explosé indéfiniment c'est tout
simplement parce que comme le pétrole
est un facteur limitant de l'économie à
partir du moment où une ressource et
physiquement un facteur limitant de
l'économique
si vous en avez - vous ne gardez pas une
demande identique et donc un prix qui
augmentent à défilement vous casser la
demande parce que vous casser le pib est
à ce moment vous avez les prix qui se
réajuste d'une autre manière
voilà j'espère que c'était à peu près
clair mais c'est pour faire comprendre
que vous ne pouvez pas bougé simplement
l'offre avec une demande qui reste
constante finalement j'aurais pu dire
comme ça et à ce moment effectivement
vous avez quelque chose qui ressemble à
une élasticité qui s'applique et vous
voyez votre prix augmenter indéfiniment
alors pour finir sur l'histoire du prix
il ya quelques années j'avais théorisé
de manière un peu simple et j'en ai
parlé à un économiste qui s'appelle
hilaric landes qui fait partie du comité
des experts du shift et qui est par
ailleurs un des fondateurs dauphine la
mathématicien et je lui avais expliqué
pourquoi à mon sens dans un univers
contre 1
le prix du pétrole devrait devenir ni
durablement aussi durablement bas et
durablement aussillon et alors le
mécanisme que j'avais en tête est le
suivant alors comme c'est un cycle je
peux le prendre de n'importe où vous
avez une offre de pétrole qui est ce
qu'elle est comme le pétrole
à ce moment là alors imaginons que le
pétrole à ce moment là ne vont pas très
cher du coup les gens ont envie d'en
consommer plus parce que ça procure plus
de transport dans plus de liberté donc
on est chez en cherchant consommer plus
mais comme par ailleurs le prix du
pétrole n'est pas très élevé
les producteurs de pétrole n'ont pas
envie de développer de nouveaux projets
pour trouver du pétrole
parce que ils se disent que ça a toutes
les chances de ne pas être rentable
donc ils investissent pas comme les
champs en exploitation baisse ils ont
une dépression naturelle qui est de
l'ordre paraît-il deal a lieu
aujourd'hui de 9 % par an absolument
considérable enfin même si c'est si
c'est pas tellement ce que je vais
expliquer à ce moment sans
investissement significatif
l'offre de pétrole a tendance à se
tasser un peu où elles augmentent moins
vite que ce qu'elle pourrait augmenter
enfin peu importe alors que la demande
elle a envie d'augmenter parce que les
gens sont habitués à un pétrole pas cher
à ce moment via un moment où vous avez à
chaque de prix parce qu'il n'y a plus
assez de pétrole pour satisfaire la
demande a cependant le prix explosent et
à ce moment le consommateur va faire l'
inverse il va se mettre lui à se
restreindre
parce qu'ils trouvent que c'est trop
cher sans compter que s'il n'y a plus
assez de pétrole à ce moment ça casse le
pib ce qui fait une deuxième raison pour
que le consommateur se restreignent
alors que dans le même temps le
producteur se dit gamme bon puisque le
prix explosent là je vais commencer à
investir dans de nouveaux projets pour
offrir du pétrole en plus et à ce moment
vous avez donc le prix du pétrole a
fortement augmenté mais les
consommateurs se sont restreints le prix
du pétrole y ait augmenté en pétrole
supplémentaires arrivent sur le marché
puisque les producteurs ont investi
alors même que le consommateur lui il a
envie de moins de pétrole et à ce moment
juste derrière vous allez avoir un
contre-choc super que pris la semaine à
faire exactement l'inversé de ce que je
viens d'évoquer
et à ce moment on est reparti pour un
tour priba sous investissement mais de
vente de consommation supplémentaire etc
donc dans un monde où le pétrole est
contraint et où il suffit pas d'investir
1 $ pour faire jaillir des milliards de
barils comme c'était le cas au début du
pétrole c'est comme c'est le cas
maintenant c'est à dire avec des
investissements chers qui sont
nécessaires et un prix du pétrole élevés
qui est nécessaire pour faire sortir du
pétrole est bien le prix du pétrole
il rentre dans un système où sion où les
investissements et le comportement du
consommateur évolué de manière
contrastée clic et vous êtes obligés
d'avoir un prix du pétrole qui va aussi
y ait en étant ni durablement au nid
durablement bas c'est une des raisons
qui expliquent pourquoi quand
personnellement on me demande de
m'exprimer sur ce que sera le prix futur
du pétrole je fais très exactement la
réponse que je viens de faire
je dis que je ne crois pas une seconde
au fait qu'il va monter à 100 puis 200
puis 300 puis 400 et 500 dollars le
baril par contre ce que je crois c'est
que s'il est contraint il va se mettra
aussi par contre ce que je crois aussi
pour en revenir à la première partie
cette explication c'est que si le
pétrole devient de plus en plus
contraint le pib a baissé de moins en
moins de pétrole ça va faire baisser le
pib donc le prix nominal du baril ne va
pas changer
par contre le pouvoir d'achat du
consommateur rêver c est donc le prix
qui va vraiment augmenter indéfiniment
et celui là il va vraiment augmenter
indéfiniment
c'est le prix rapporté au pouvoir
d'achat dit autrement le temps qu'il
faut travailler
le nombre de minutes de travail qu'il
faut consacrer au fait de se payer un
litre d'essence alors ce temps-là
considérablement baissé depuis le début
de l'ère du pétrole
et c'est celui là qui va se remettre à
augmenter de manière significative
quand le pétrole commencera vraiment à
devenir contre alors
maintenant nous allons passer ah oui il
ya une question sur les sens avec le
charbon c'est comme ça que hitler a fait
voler ses avions ait avancé ses chars
donc c'est tout à fait possible c'est
capitalistique et l'on perd la moitié de
l'énergie en cours de route donc c'est
tout à fait possible mais question
intéressante dans une société low tech
quelle place pour l'armée alors l'armée
est quelque chose qui malheureusement a
toujours été
comment dire une organisation humaine à
partir qui est qui a été présente à
partir du moment où les hommes se sont
considérés comme étant suffisamment
nombreux pour être en compétition les
uns avec les autres
donc vous avez des tas d'animaux dans la
nature qui se livrent des combats de mal
là pour séduire les femelles en
généralise zigouille pas quelques
exceptions près les hommes alors c'est
pas pour les femelles en l'occurrence
qui se battent encore que ça leur arrive
c'est pour l'espace vital et à ce moment
ils sont parfaitement capables de
sigoyer les uns des autres
malheureusement on a eu de nombreux
exemples alors les los teques n'empêche
pas du tout d'avoir des armées du reste
les hutus et les tutsis se sont
massacrés de manière parfaitement los
teques avec des machettes
donc le fait qu' on est une société low
tech ne supprime pas l'armée ne supprime
pas le fait qu' on ait envie de se
mettre dessus
par contre ça supprime à l'évidence
quand on a peu d'énergie vous rappelez
de gaulle qui préconise l armée
mécanisée dont préconisé l'armée
mécanisée pour de gaulle en fait c'est
préconisé le recours aux esclaves
énergétique c'est très exactement ça
donc une armée avec - d'esclaves
énergétique et bien c'est une armée dans
laquelle on reviendra à la baïonnette et
à la lance jeu précis ça sera très très
agréable pour les gens qui auront à se
battre mais enfin c'est à peu près aussi
simple que ça dans un premier temps il
est absolument évident que il va y avoir
une compétition pour les ressources
restantes qui mobilisera les armes et
mécanisée existantes et c'est du reste
un vrai risque pour la paix dans le
monde puisque à mesure que l'on
comprendra qu on a des problèmes de
court terme qu'on n'a pas été capable
d'anticiper sur la dépendance aux
énergies fossiles la tentation d'aller
se servir chez ceux qui en on sera
évidemment croissante surtout si ceux
qui en ont
des très grosses d'armé et que ceux qui
en ont besoin ont désormais beaucoup
plus conséquente
alors maintenant le petit couplet nuque
les deux questions qui me paraissent
intéressantes
une première c'est sur les ressources en
uranium et qui du reste est très très
lié à la question d'astrid vous avez
actuellement dans le monde
un nucléaire qui représente entre 10 et
15% 12 je crois on je suis plus enfin
dans ces eaux-là de la production
électrique ce nucléaire la consomment
aujourd'hui 70 mille tonnes d'uranium
par an
les réserves connues d'uranium
représente aujourd'hui au prix auquel on
accède d'uranium au prix auquel on prend
l'uranium sur le marché 5 millions de
tonnes
je vous le redis à cette allée donc on a
un siècle pour un parc qui aujourd'hui
représente 11% de la production
électrique mondiale
ça veut dire que si le parc devait ne
serait ce que représente et non pas 11
mai 50% de la production électrique
mondiale c'est là que je dire tout
charbon pour le remplacer par du
nucléaire 40% de la production et de
sept mondial avec les réserves connues
on tient 20 ans je rajoute les réserves
additionnelles ça veut dire que je
triple des réserves connues qui était de
5 millions de tonnes je les passe à 15
millions voire à 20 millions vous voyez
que allez on tient pas 20 ans où il ya
50 ans ou 60 à 70 bref on n'est pas du
tout dans le bon ordre de grandeur pour
que le nucléaire puisse contribuer
durablement un approvisionnement
énergétique qui aurait à one
approvisionnement électrique pour être
plus précis qui aurait ne serait-ce que
remplacer les centrales à charbon
existante sans parler de
l'électrification en plus des transports
et de ceci et de cela alors je rassure
les amoureux des énergies renouvelables
on y arrivera encore moins avec les
nerfs
mais il est évident que doudou le
premier couplet sur cette intervention
qui est de toute façon on n'échappera
pas à la bise au régime et la question
c'est est ce qu'on va devoir savoir
gérer ça de manière organisée pas trop
douloureuse sympathique et c est la
notion de parachute ventre mais donc si
l'on revient à la question des réserves
il est évident qu'un nucléaire qui se
limite à la fission de l'uranium 235 ne
représente pas une marge de manoeuvre
massive
en ce qui concerne sa contribution à la
décarbonation incidemment des centrales
nucléaires qui se rajoute aux centrales
à charbon existante ne m'intéresse pas
plus
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est du clerc
qui tue le charbon le reste je m'en
fiche ou qui tue le gaz
mais voilà et c'est les deux nucléaire
qui m'intéresse le nucléaire qui vient
se rajouter en plus du charbon et du gaz
existants m'intéresse beaucoup moins
donc le nucléaire à base de fission
d'uranium 235 n'est pas une marge de
manoeuvre qui permet de entre guillemets
décarbonés d'électricité mondiale au
niveau auquel on la consomme
actuellement et même si on en consomme
que la moitié pendant des siècles
ce qui veut dire que le nucléaire qui
est vraiment durable c'est le nucléaire
dit de quatrième génération qui permet
d'exploiter la fission de l'uranium 238
mais ceux qui demandent de neutrons au
lieu d'un donc en fait le premier nôtre
on va vous transformer d'uranium 238 en
plutonium 239 qui lui est fissile est ce
plutonium 239 peu fissionner comme de
l'uranium 235 en produisant des
quantités d'énergie considérable pour
ceux qui n'ont jamais entendu je fais
une petite parenthèse vous avez la même
quantité d'énergie libérée par la
fission d'un gramme de matière que par
la combustion d'une tonne de pétrole
encore donc fissionner un gramme
d'uranium ça libère autant d'énergie
qu'une tonne de pétrole
ça explique pourquoi la fission
nucléaire est une énergie qui permet ait
un est un mode de production électrique
qui permet de fournir de très grandes
quantités d'électricité avec de toutes
petites quantités de matière
contrairement à la combustion et ça
explique pourquoi le bilan carbone
nucléaire est par construction à bilan
carbone faible parce que même si vous
avez besoin de diesel
pour l'extraction minière pour les
transports intermédiaire pour la
construction de la centrale pour le
traitement des déchets etc
sa porte sur des toutes petites
quantités de matières qu'il faut
manipuler et donc ramené au
kilowattheure produit ce facteur de 1 1
million derrière entre l'énergie
chimique et l'énergie nucléaire vous
écrase totalement les émissions de co2
par kilowattheure c'est la raison pour
laquelle le nucléaire est une trêve avec
une énergie à très faible contenu en
carbone par kilowattheure sa réponse
soit dit en passant aussi à la question
sur le pétrole oui le nucléaire
aujourd'hui a besoin du pétrole
il a besoin du pétrole pour les engins
2000 il a besoin de pétrole pour les
transports il a besoin du pétrole
courroux du chardon pour faire le ciment
pour construire la centrale
mais tout ça reste des petites quantités
d'hydrocarbures rapporté à la quantité
de nucléaire prendra d'énergie produite
donc on pourrait très bien imaginer que
tout ça marche avec des biocarburants et
de charbon de bois pour faire la sq et
de la centrale ça passerait encore si
les seuls besoins en carburant liquide
sur terre et en charbon de bois sur
terre était pour faire le béton l'acier
et de la centrale et pour faire
l'extraction minière de l'uranium
ça passe encore c'est pas un c'est pas
un problème par contre c'est clair
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas fait de cette
manière et donc il ya une dépendance au
pétrole
c'est tout à fait exact si j'en reviens
donc à ma question du nucléaire de cette
rime génération il est nécessaire pour
avoir un nucléaire durable
qu'est ce que j'appelle un nucléaire
durable c'est un nucléaire qui fait que
l'humanité ne mourra pas d'un problème
lié à la disponibilité de l'uranium pour
faire de l'électricité à la presse du
charbon voilà on est bien parti pour
mourir tout un tas d'autres trucs
ce que je suis en train d'évoquer ne
règle pas le problème de l'érosion des
sols de l'effondrement de la
biodiversité soit dit en passant pour la
biodiversité le nucléaire quelque chose
de beaucoup plus sympathique que les
énergies renouvelables diffuse qui
demande d occupation de surfaces
beaucoup plus importante d extraction
minière beaucoup plus importante
le nucléaire demande des surfaces
beaucoup plus faible et en plus si je
suis un peu cynique quand une centrale
éloigne rapidement les humains ça crée
une réserve de biodiversité dont la
nature nos élèves un peu violent méthode
de création d'un espace naturel
cela étant ça marche très bien les
énergies renouvelables type les barrages
ont conduit à l'évacuation de beaucoup
plus de gens et on inonde est beaucoup
plus d'écosystèmes donc le nucléaire
c'est pas mal pour la biodiversité c'est
plutôt une énergie assez sympathique de
ce point de vue par contre comme je le
disais nucléarisé l'électricité au
charbon aujourd'hui ne résout pas tous
les problèmes loin s'en faut donc je
suis en train de parler de quelque chose
qui est intéressant à faire très loin
d'être la totalité du de la entre
guillemets solution donc pour que ce
soit durable c'est-à-dire qu'on meure
d'autres choses
eh bien il faut que on passe rapidement
au nucléaire de quatrième génération
permettant de en gros x 200 l'horizon de
temps des ressources et auquel cas sa
part de sens si on explique que
l'uranium et par 506 en exploitant plus
le thorium est donc là l'humanité morte
ou d'autres choses avant d'être morte
d'un problème de pénurie d'uranium pour
faire tourner des centrales
qu'est ce que ça veut dire de passer au
nucléaire de quatrième génération
ça veut dire essentiellement être
capable de faire fonctionner dès ce
qu'on appelle des surgénérateurs c'est à
dire des réacteurs dans lesquelles la
réaction de fission initialement
déclenchée par de l'uranium 235 parce
qu'on en a besoin comme allumette pour
allumer la réaction derrière
créée en continu de la création de
combustible additionnel en pratique
l'uranium 238 qui est mélangé à
l'uranium 235 et qui en constitue même
99% à l'état naturel enfin 99,5 et qui
en capturant des neutrons se transforme
en combustible fissile qui derrière fils
y sommes donc vous rajoutez l'uranium
238 au fur et à mesure dans la soupe et
la soupe continue de chauffer ses
réacteurs là la france sait en faire un
dessin on va dire une façon de faire qui
est phénix et superphénix
donc la france a fait fonctionner
pendant trente ans sans problème un
réacteur de recherche qui s'appelle
félix dont la puissance électrique était
de 200 mégawatts
donc c'est pas mal l'arrivée à c'est un
septième de la puissance d'un ep r c'est
un quart de la puissance des plus petits
réacteurs électrogènes en fonctionnement
actuellement dans le parc français donc
ce n'est pas du tout ridicule et ce
réacteur à fonctionner très bien
fonctionné ça marche il ya pas de
problème c'est un réacteur qui utilisent
le sodium fondu comme caloporteur et
alors qu'il ya des inconvénients de
sodium il brûle mais il a un avantage
c'est que le sodium ne s'active pas
c'est à dire que quand il n'y a pas
moyen de transformer en truck radio
actif treize ans kittin ans quand ils
capturent des neutrons qui s'échappe de
la réaction de fission d'accord il n'y a
pas deux il ya pas de dessous produits
indésirables à longue durée de vie
radioactifs etc qui est lié à ça donc ça
ça a très bien marché et c'est en train
de finir alors ça a été arrêté pour
raisons politiques comme super phénix
à chaque fois c'est la gauche au pouvoir
qui a dit allez on va s'acheter les voix
des anti nucléaires et donc on va
sacrifier un totem 1 tout comme
fessenheim même principe et pas plus
réfléchie que ça et mais ça marche très
bien
les chinois sont en train de se lancer à
fond là-dedans les russes sont en train
de se lancer à fond on attend donc du
nucléaire de quatrième génération il y
en aura sur terre c'est absolument
certain du nucléaire tout court du reste
tant que l'humanité n'a pas disparu et
qui reste un semblant de civilisation
industrielle il en restera sur terre
aussi puisque les chinois se préoccupe
assez peu nos états d'âme sans quoi ils
ont bien raison
quelque part moi je me dis qu'ils ont
tout intérêt à financer chez nous la
mouvance antinucléaire parce que le jour
où on se rendra compte qu'on peut pas
faire sans parce que les éoliennes sont
pas que rien ne permette pas à l'hôpital
de fonctionner les jours sans vent et 1
3 c'est insupportable et de permettre au
supermarché d'être ouvert les jours sans
vent et on trouve assez insupportable à
ce moment les chinois nous dirons nous
l'aimons de nos centrales et de dire oui
donc je pense que en tout cas si j'étais
à leur place je finance fait grassement
le mouvement anti nucléaire français en
conjonction avec les gaziers donc le
pour en venir je dis pas que les gaziers
les finances utiliserait intérêt à le
faire donc en conjonction avec le la
partie
regardons avec ce que je dis juste avant
donc le nucléaire de quatrième
génération est absolument indispensable
alors la france avait un programme de
recherche qui s'appelle astrid qui n'est
pas très loin d'être une réédition de
félix superphénix qui avaient soit dit
en passant un autre intérêt c'est que ça
minimise la quantité de déchets qui sort
du réacteur
c'est à dire que ce qu'on appelle les
actinides mineurs c'est à dire les
éléments plus lourds que l'uranium les
transferts amiens ont la particularité
de former une partie des déchets
nucléaires notamment le plutonium que
aujourd'hui qui aujourd'hui contribuent
à la longévité des déchets et également
à leurs activités
la quantité de radioactivité qui vont
libérer ensuite une partie de ces
éléments dans les réacteurs
surgénérateurs sont incinérés c'est à
dire que ils vont eux-mêmes fissionner
absorber des neutrons puis fissionner en
libérant de l'énergie et du coup en
disparaissant puisque la fission fait
disparaître les noyau initial
donc c'est un c'est un programme
évidemment intéressant alors comment
interpréter la décision de macron dans
cette affaire d'arrêter le programme
astrid du ceva je souscris
malheureusement à une tribune au vitriol
qui a été écrite dans la rue
progressiste par l'ancien haut
commissaire à l'énergie atomique qui
s'appelle yves bréchet et dont le titre
et de mémoire l'arrêt d'astrid un cas
d'école de disparition de l'état
stratège je crois que c'est très
exactement ça le titre de la tribune que
je vous invite à lire parce que elle est
malheureusement
comment dire c'est triste qu'il ait eu
besoin de l'écrire mais par contre elle
est extrêmement bien tourner très bien
argumenté extrêmement incisif et
caustique beaucoup d'humour et ça dit
très exactement que l'état vient de
faire l'exact inverse de ce qui fait de
ce qu'il fallait faire alors certes
pourrait objecter que aujourd'hui dans
le climat actuel de défiance du
nucléaire qui s'empare de manière
croissante du pays
peut-être que l'état n'avait pas les
moyens de sa politique
alors il y avait une solution qui
permettait de maintenir ce programme en
faisant une sortie par le haut cette
solution c'est quelque chose que j'ai
déjà évoqué qui est un programme
fasttrack sur la quatrième génération
alors ce programme fasttrack je
l'imaginé comme suit évidemment très
très perfectible mais c'était un c'est
quelque chose qui me paraissent elles
pas complètement stupide il est initié
par la france qui pour les raisons qui
vont suivre est le seul pays européen
qui est capable aujourd'hui de prendre
cette initiative parce qu'il faut avoir
un certain poids économique
il faut avoir une industrie nucléaire
chez soi il faut avoir une recherche qui
était hier chez soi extrêmement
significative donc la france donne le
top départ
la france dit alors je me dire après ce
que la france propose mais cette
proposition elle commence par là faire
la grande bretagne en grande bretagne
vous avez aujourd'hui une union sacrée
tous partis confondus sur la question du
changement climatique et par ailleurs
vous avez une approche extrêmement
pragmatique sur les sources de carbone
donc en gros les grands bretons ont
disent nous on prend tout on compare en
garde ce qui est plus intéressant en
fait ceci en fait de cela dont on va
faire du nucléaire va faire de l'éolien
offshore et doit le but c'est de se
séparer du charbon et du gaz et le
charbon qui sont en train d'y arriver
donc l'on va voir la grande bretagne
ils ont une coopération industrielle
avec nous sur le nucléaire actuelle
c'est bien le bout du monde s'ils sont
pas d'accord pour faire quelque chose
sur nucléaire de quatrième génération
une fois que la grande bretagne vous a
dit vivre vous allez voir les finlandais
alors les finlandais comme vous le savez
on construit un premier réacteur avec
les français il aime beaucoup le
nucléaire finalement les français donc
ils vont en faire un deuxième avec
rosatom c'est à dire et on dit au
nucléaire au finlandais qui sont des
gens très pragmatique aussi est ce que
vous voulez pas monté dans cette barque
après on va voir les suédois une fois
que les finlandais ont dit oui
et vraisemblablement que les suédois
vont ouvrir une oreille intéressée
surtout si les anglais ont dit oui parce
qu'ils sont très proches des anglais
ensuite vous allez voir les bataves
c'est à dire les hollandais qui
aujourd'hui sont en train de changer
d'avis sur ce sujet c'est à dire qu'il
ya eu un vote au parlement il ya pas
longtemps disant nucléaire faut
commencer à regarder
comme vous le savez probablement les
hollandais sont en perte il était
exportateur de gaz depuis des décennies
grâce à leur grand champ super géant de
grenages dont ils ont arrêté
l'exploitation parce qu'en fait le chant
est maintenant suffisamment déplétés
pour qu'il commence à se tasser et à
créer des tremblements de terre au
moment où istace qui font respecter les
habitants donc il y avait encore un peu
de gaz à sortir mais les hollandais ont
pris les devants en disant bon on arrête
on arrête donc il va avoir un tout petit
sujet sur la production électrique
surtout que la mer du nord est en déclin
aussi ensuite nous allons voir les
tchèques les tchèques ont très envie de
faire du nucléaire
nous allons voir les polonais qui seront
tout à fait d'accord pour se lancer dans
le nucléaire de quatrième génération
on complète avec les hongrois et les
roumains qui ont par ailleurs bien
besoin de s'arrimer à l'europe et enfin
on finit avec les espagnols qui dans le
climat actuel et peut-être même les
italiens qui sont pas un fou tu nous
dire et alors qu'est ce qu'on propose à
tous ces gens là on leur dit voilà on va
faire un programme accéléré de
recherches pour mettre au point des
réacteurs industrielle de quatrième
génération est ce qu on vous proposait
la chose suivante il ya actuellement
douze dessins de quatrième génération
les uns imagine qu'on va faire du
graphite les autres pas de grafite les
avec du gaz comme caloporteur les oatei
de l'eau les uns avec ceux ci les autres
etc cela les actes du thorium
les uns font l'hydrogène les autres par
mois donc vous avez là dedans douze
dessins on se met autour de la table
dans les pays qui se sont réunis donc on
n'est que des européens on est moins
d'une dizaine et on se dit voilà on se
met d'accord sur le fait que dans les
douze dessins on va en retenir quatre ou
cinq dans les quatre ou cinq c'est
évident qu'ils râlent uranium plutonium
à sa bien le fonds duke c'est à dire
astrid phoenix superphénix mais pas que
il faut évidemment qui est un réacteur à
sels fondus voire deux c'est à dire un
uranium plutonium 1a thorium il faut
qu'ils aient voilà il faut il faut
regarder
quelques dessins mais pas beaucoup et on
dit chacun de ses dessins on va
construire deux prototypes pas un mais
deux comme ça on est sûr que si l'un des
pays qui doit construire un prototype
foire eh bien on a pas foirer autour
d'expériences sur le prototype en
question et chaque pays participant à
l'expérience et au consortium
construit en maîtrise d'oeuvre délégué
total c'est à dire
il est totalement libre de faire ce
qu'il veut et pas comme pour iter
l'étrange le mandarine doit venir du
japon une autre tranche de mandarine
doit venir d'espagne etc
ça sort pas et la vi vient d'allemagne
et le boulon vient de chez paou des
états unis
donc chaque pays construit en maîtrise
d'oeuvre délégué total sur son sol avec
la part du budget qui revient un
prototype d'un des dessins ici dépasse
comme il est libre de faire ce qu'il
veut c'est pour ses pieds donc ils
abondent
c'est lui qui paye le déplacement si on
fait ça on en a pour très exactement
quinze ans avant d'avoir terminé la
construction des prototypes
on en a pour 25 ans à partir de
maintenant t0 pour avoir terminé le
retour d'expérience sur les prototypes
et à la fin des retours d'expérience on
sait où sont des dessins qu'on a
vraiment envie de privilégier et on se
lance dans la construction de tête de
série dans un programme de cette nature
dans très exactement 30 ans vous avez de
quoi commencer à prendre le relais à
large échelle des réacteurs à uranium
235 qu'on a aujourd'hui
alors je le redis ça résoudra pas la
totalité des problèmes mondiaux
ça peut déjà permettre à l'europe
commençons par balayer devant chez nous
d'avoir un nucléaire durable qui
remplace durablement le charbon européen
qui toute façon étant déplétion et voilà
la réponse que personnellement
j'aimerais faire en ce qui concerne le
nucléaire de quatrième génération
j'ai été proposé ce programme à deux
administrateurs généraux du ceva
l'un et l'autre qu'ils ont l'un et
l'autre écouté d'une oreille intéressée
et jamais rien fait alors il se trouve
que malheureusement
dans notre pays bien évidemment un
patron d'administration ne fera rien
sans pouvoir politique et comme
aujourd'hui le pouvoir politique
considère que le nucléaire c'est caca
globalement on n'en est pas encore
revenu de cette affaire là j'ai
malheureusement peu d'espoir que ce que
je viens d'évoquer prennent place alors
vous aurez remarqué que dans cette
affaire je propose de faire le tour de
l'allemagne
c'est donc une espèce de manoeuvre
d'encerclement ça ne veut pas du tout
dire qu'on ferme la porte à l'allemagne
ça veut dire qu'on se met en position de
négocier avec les allemands dans un
rapport du fort au faible ou le forcer
nous parce que tant qu'on négocie 1
point le forcer donc on n'a strictement
aucune chance de leur faire entendre
raison sur quoi que ce soit concernant
le nucléaire peut être que en interne
fillon par changer d'avis mais sûrement
pas à cause de lui alors que dans
l'articulation que je propose est dans
ma foi il ya une petite chance que les
choses puissent aller de l'avant et
toute façon si on fait ça en coopération
restreinte
on n'a pas besoin d'eux si on a la masse
critique d'argent pour faire des choses
ou le fait point
voilà ce que j'avais envie de dire sur
le nucléaire de quatrième génération
donc pour synthétiser il est absolument
indispensable sinon on n'y arrive pas
sur les risques le nucléaire dans un
monde qui s'effondre à ça aussi c'est un
truc très intéressant alors je vais je
vais vous donner deux indications dont
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure il suffit
qu'il reste un tout petit peu de pétrole
est un tout petit peu de charbon pour
faire juste les centrales et la chaîne
amont du combustible pour que ça marche
toujours
le nucléaire est né dans un monde qui
était beaucoup moins entre guillemets
riche qu'aujourd'hui puisque le
nucléaire est né en 1942 avec la pile de
fermi et que dans les années 50 on a
développé des prototypes d'absolument
tout et n'importe quoi à une époque où
l'informatique n'existait pas c'est à
dire qu'un réacteur ça fonctionne de
manière analogique sans aucun problème
ce qui n'est pas le cas soit ditt en
passant du photovoltaïque et de l'éolien
qui ont besoin d'une électronique de
puissance pour être capable d'alimenter
un réseau sans que l'horizon saute et
donc qui ne sont absolument pas capable
de résister à une suppression des moyens
numériques modernes alors que le
nucléaire est capable puisqu'il est né
dans un univers n'avait qu'elle n'y
avait pas de moyens numériques modernes
nucléaire est capable de fonctionner de
manière analogique de bout en bout le
donc ça c'est un premier élément
le deuxième élément c'est le cas de
l'ukraine qui est intéressant rappelez
vous savez que l'ukraine est un pays qui
a connu un terrible accident en 1986 qui
est l'accident de tchernobyl
après quoi en 1989
ils ont connu à deuxième accident qui
n'était pas beaucoup plus drôle qui est
la chute du mur de berlin et la division
du pib ukrainien par deux pourriez-vous
dire dans ce genre de contexte le pays
est un peu secoué il se trouve que dans
ce genre de contexte l'ukraine a doublé
sa production électrique par sa
production nucléaire par pardon qui
était celle d'avant tchernobyl donc la
production nucléaire ukrainienne
aujourd'hui et le double d'avant
tchernobyl au moment où cette production
a doublé le pib a été divisé par deux et
donc effondrement économique
effondrement des structures la
transition a quand même été quelque
chose qui a secoué les structures de
manière extrêmement violente et bien à
ce moment-là l'ukraine n'a pas eu
d'accident alors c'est pas une preuve
évidemment irréfutable pourra toujours
objecter que dans le cas d'espèce ne
fait pas une généralité
je suis tout à fait d'accord mais il est
quand même intéressant de noter que le
moment où on aurait pu se dire que le
contexte ambiant favorise de plus la
survenue d'un pépin c'est à dire le pib
qui s'écroulent les institutions qui
sont en déshérence
et bien c'est pas à ce moment là on a eu
un gros pépin sur une centrale
c'est dans un système très dirigé
soviétique où soit dit en passant pour
ceux d'entre vous qui connaissent les
détails par ex assez bien reflété dans
la série car mobile que j'ai pas regardé
mais que le la le fait qu'on ait
délibérément demandé aux opérateurs de
faire une connerie ce qui est tout à
fait vrai est assez bien reflété dans le
dans la syrie voilà donc donc l'idée que
une forte contraction du pib et des
soubresauts fort dans la chaîne de
commandement induisent nécessairement
fin d'un pas dans la chaîne de
commandement reprises dans les
institutions induisent nécessairement
est par construction un énorme et
dépeint sur une centrale
ben la vie montre que c'est pas
nécessairement aussi simple que ça
encore une fois c'est pas du tout une
garantie bien ce que je suis en train de
lire mais c'est juste une voix invite à
la réflexion sur le fait qu' il n'est
pas dit que ce soit la fin du monde
nécessairement par ailleurs quelque
chose qui est intéressant c'est que
enfin quel sens il doit dire intéressant
il est à noter c'est que si vous
conservez les centrales avec une
quelques dispositifs qui font que le
coeur peut fondre à l'intérieur sans que
ça gêne ce qui se passe à l'extérieur il
faut bien voir que ce qui peut se passer
de plus grave à ce moment c'est un
accident de type three mile island c'est
à dire que vous perdez la centrale du
coup vous perdez l'approvisionnement
électrique
c'est évidemment un autre lieu mais vous
ne faites rien de plus emmerdant que ça
à l'extérieur alors rien de plus en
garde en cas de perte
d'approvisionnement électrique dans un
monde qui en dépendent en totalité c'est
effectivement lieu quand même mais ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que dans
un monde qui s'effondre et donc qui a
besoin de moins en moins d'électricité
entre autres choses le fait que vous
ayez dans une centrale un coeur qui font
ça ne sera pas le premier problème
auquel la civilisation soit confronté à
ce moment là le risque d assassinats en
série et des guerres civiles à la
machette type hutu tutsi me paraît dans
ce genre de contexte
hélas beaucoup plus élevé aucun pour ma
propre progéniture
ça me fait infiniment plus peur que le
risque nucléaire donc aménagement du
territoire juillet j ai répondu
petite question sur petites questions
sur tombe aux mains à tien l'ouverture
de la sncf à la concurrence
c'est rigolo c'est l'ouverture de la
sncf à la concurrence l'ouverture de la
sncf à la concurrence est un moyen
supplémentaire de détricoter un monopole
régulé et c'est malheureusement pour moi
en fait c'est pas tellement la sncf qui
a l'air facile c'est intéressant mais
c'est malheureusement pour moi
emblématique de l'inversion des
priorités qui s'est emparée de l'europe
et qui est quelque chose qui risque
assez sûrement malheureusement de faire
imploser ce système
au moment où l'europe s'est fondée
l'europe a dit ce qu'on veut c'est la
paix entre les peuples et pour que les
peuples se connaissent il faut qu'il
fasse des choses ensemble
alors dans les choses qu'on peut faire
ensemble ces affaires donc on s'est dit
on va faire sauter les limites aux
affaires entre les peuples européens
après quoi le moyen est devenu un
objectif en soi
et donc aujourd'hui la croissance du pib
qui est leur l'article 3 du traité
instaurant l'union européenne du traité
de lisbonne et la suppression de toutes
les barrières aux échanges quelle
qu'elle soit et la suppression de toute
entrave à la concurrence quelles
qu'elles soient sont devenus non pas des
moyens au service de l'appel parce que
sinon on se rendrait compte qu'on est en
train d'en bouffer jusqu'à la nausée
mais c'est devenu des fins en soi et ses
fins en soi malheureusement vont
conduire très exactement à faire
imploser
cet édifice magique que nous avions
construit et qui a effectivement
préserver la paix depuis 1945 de
l'atlantique à l'oural
ce qu'on est en train de faire en ce
moment c'est de penser que plus de
concurrence amène plus de bonheur no
matter what donc on a un système en
france qui marche
bon sinon en grève de temps en temps il
va le faire dans quelques semaines pour
des raisons qui n'ont rien à voir soit
dit en passant
avec l'organisation de la sncf et tout à
voir avec le droit de grève
donc la solution au problème qui va
démarrer le 5 décembre ne s'appelle pas
casser le monopole de la sncf
il s'appelle éventuellement mettre dans
la constitution le fait que n'importe
qui n'a pas le droit de faire grève
jusqu'à plus soif et n'importe comment
voilà je suis un sujet ça peut très bien
décider que c'est comme ça que ça doit
se passer mais par contre dire on a un
système qui marche bien on va le cassé
en petits morceaux ça marchera encore
mieux je ne vois pas tellement l'intérêt
d'allouer nos ressources notre temps
notre jus de cerveau et l'otan qui n'est
pas rattrapable
ak c'est un truc qui marche plutôt que
de s'occuper des trucs qui marchent pas
donc pour moi c'est une approche
idéologique est absolument pas
pragmatique qui conduit à ce système
vous remarquerez qu en france on a cassé
le système électrique qu'on avait on a
transformé sa en plusieurs morceaux le
réseau de transport d'un côté de réseaux
de distribution de l'autre le système de
production puis on a dit aux systèmes de
production quand même c'est pas sympa
que tu soit rentable donc on va te faire
des tas de misère par exemple tu vas
vendre l'électricité à prix coûtant à
tes concurrents
comme ça on va faire passer soit dit en
passant la rente qui était captée par un
opérateur public pour en reverser ses
dividendes à l'état à des opérateurs
privés qui n'ont aucune intention de
reverser leurs dividendes à l'état donc
la mise en concurrence des opérateurs
c'est juste un système qui permet de
transférer de la rente de d'une entité
détenue par tout le monde à une entité
détenue par quelques-uns jeu
complètement persuadés que ce soit une
avancée sociale absolument majeur donc
le détricotage ddf est un truc qui n'a
eu aucun intérêt durée j'avais publié
dès 2002 ou 2003 je me rappelle plus une
tribune en disant que l'ouverture des
marchés de l'électricité à la
concurrence était une connerie majeur et
qu'on s'en mordrait les doigts pour un
mec plus intelligent que la moyenne
s'était il suffisait juste de regarder
comment système été fait c'était très
simple de voir que c'était ça qui allait
se passer
et de fait c'est très exactement ça qui
s'est passé donc aujourd'hui on a un
système des plus piloter et on est
obligé de remettre des cadres
extrêmement rigide dans le système si on
veut qu'ils se dirigent dans une
direction donnée donc par exemple pour
le développement des énergies
renouvelables enfin de l'éolien et du
solaire
on a été obligé de remettre dans le
système un cadre extrêmement dirigiste
c'est à dire des tarifs d'achat garantis
donc en fait on a renationalisé cette
partie là de la production électrique du
cerveau d'une certaine manière
indépendamment du fait qu'elle soit
intéressant tout intéressant c'est pas
le sujet à ce stade dont seuls propos
est de montrer qu'on a été obligés de
renationaliser d'une certaine manière
cette production éolienne et solaire
pour arriver là où on voulait arriver
c'est à dire à ce que ça se débloque pas
ce que spontanément les acteurs n'ont
aucune raison de faire ce que la
collectivité estime termina pertinent à
partir du moment où chacun stipule pour
lui-même
ils vont faire ce qui est pertinent mode
et l'idée que ce qui est pertinent pour
eux est pertinent pour la collectivité
ballon ça marche pas donc dans les
systèmes qui sont des systèmes
comment dire dans les dents les objets
qui sont des objets régaliens c'est à
dire le pays peut pas s'en passer
je fais partie des gens qui considèrent
que à monopole ou un oligopole encadré
c'est beaucoup plus efficace que la
libre concurrence à laval et la libre
concurrence à laval de l'électricité est
une connerie je les dis ya longtemps je
persiste et signe
et bien la libre concurrence dans le
domaine ferroviaire sera au mieux
un truc qui ne va rien amené et au pire
une perte de temps qui va consacrer des
tas de cervelle de consultants de mecs
de bercy 2 etc à des conneries qui n'ont
strictement aucun intérêt
alors que par ailleurs il ya le feu à la
maison et qu'on s'occupe pas et qu'on
met pas des moyens dans les choses qui
sont vraiment nécessaires
voilà donc c'est une manoeuvre de
diversion triste parce que toutes les
manoeuvres de diversion son triste quand
on est dans une course contre la montre
donc si ça ne tenait qu'à moi je
remettrai tout ça en un seul bloc
par contre il ya beaucoup à dire sur la
gestion des entreprises publiques est
une bonne manière de gérer à un monopole
encadré n'est pas de bazarder le
président tous les cinq ans en en
faisant une sucette pour député
méritants il faut aussi que l'état soit
capable de gérer ça de manière correcte
alors une bonne partie des gens en
disent ah bah si c'est plus l'état ça
sera mieux géré voir je n'ai pas
complètement sûr il appartient aussi aux
citoyens de demander à l'état de gérer
ça de manière correcte
je trouve très rassurant de ce point de
vue par exemple que la succession de la
sncf pour assurer par quelqu'un de
l'inter je trouve ça très bien je trouve
lamentable que edf indépendamment des
qualités et défauts de son président du
moment il soit impossible à une personne
de l'un terme de devenir président dédé
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui n'a
pas de sens on a besoin de quelqu'un qui
sache de quoi il parle quand ils
s'occupent de diriger cet outil alors
communiquer et programmes scolaires
tiens on n'a jamais parlé des programmes
scolaires
à votre question pourquoi est ce qu'au
chiffre project on a commencé par
s'intéresser à la question de
l'enseignement supérieur c'est parce que
dans le pays dans lequel nous sommes
modifier les programmes scolaires ça
suppose une cogestion avec les syndicats
d'enseignants et c'est un sujet a passé
la nuit avant d'arriver où que ce soit
du reste c'est un vrai sujet il est
absolument évident qu'on ne peut pas
demander à des gens de gérer
correctement un problème sans qu'il
l'ait correctement définis donc quand on
demande aux forces vives de la nation
dans le monde économique de s'occuper
correctement du problème qui ne peuvent
pas le faire tant qu'ils ne l'ont pas
compris c'est pas par le journal qui
vont arriver à le comprendre parce que
le journal n'a pas pour vocation de
faire l'éducation des masses mais elle a
vocation à raconter ce qui est dans les
communiqués de presse modulo une
interprétation qui va par dessus du
reste une illustration en est fournie
par mon canard préféré qu'ils
s'appellent les échos et qui ce matin a
fait un numéro spécial j'imagine à
l'occasion de la sortie de la coop sur
le climat les quelques articles que j'ai
lu alors j'ai pas lu tous les articles
mais les quelques articles que j ai lu
sont des articles qui sont pour certains
du gentil greenwashing pour d'autres des
professions de foi qui n'ont strictement
aucun intérêt pour d'autres encore des
affirmations qui sont assez amusantes
on va dire par exemple il ya dans un
article cosigné de bertrand piccard le
fait que de contraindre
l'approvisionnement énergétique va faire
monter le pib vous pouvez le voir cet
article est parfaitement disponibles
voilà donc quand on lit ça on se dit bon
rails du chemin donc le il aurait
beaucoup mieux fait mon journal préféré
ce matin de faire un numéro qui aurait
été une synthèse graphique illustre est
à portée de son lecteur moyen des trois
derniers rapports du giec
d'accord il aurait pris le rapport sur
le changement climatique et les terres
le rapport sur la crise
et le rapport sur 1.5 et il en aurait
fait une synthèse accessible à tous de
la manière dont le défi se présente et
il aurait rajouté à cela une synthèse
des faits saillants du world energy
outlook de décembre 2018 qui annonce le
pit qui oui qui annonce que le pic de
production du pétrole conventionnel est
passé depuis 2008 il aurait rendu un
service considérablement supérieur au
monde économique que simplement en
publiant quelques professions de foi
dans laquelle j'ai également vu sous la
plume des bars amarante de bernard
arnault que c'était l'entreprise qui
allait sauver le monde et que les
entrepreneurs faisait des choses par
passion et absolument pas évidemment
pour la taille d'un résultat net donc le
donc le la question de l'information est
absolument cruciale c'est absolument
évident et la presse il n'y arrivera pas
à la bonne vitesse donc du coup ne reste
que le système éducatif dans le système
éducatif celui qui peut aller le plus
vite parce que c'est celui où chaque
établissement est maître de ses
programmes c'est l'enseignement
supérieur donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a commencé par s'attaquer à
l'enseignement supérieur s'est par
ailleurs de là que sortent les corps
intermédiaires et les corps
intermédiaires sont ceux qui quand même
ont une forte influence sur le mouvement
général dans lequel va le pays les corps
intermédiaires c'est des gens qui ont
tous une fonction de direction
derrière ou de gestion soit les
académiques ils ont une fonction d'
influence soit des gens qui vous
travaillez dans le monde économique
ils ont une fonction de gestion que
quelque chose soit éventuellement dans
le monde politique enfin la plus
discutable et c'est des gens qui ont
souvent la confiance des gens avec qui
il travaille j'espère avoir la confiance
mais salariés en tout cas de l'essentiel
d'entre eux et dans l'essentiel des
entreprises et des administrations dans
le monde
le chef a en général la confiance des
gens qui travaillent avec lui
il ya évidemment des chefaillons des
emmerdeurs partout comme 5% mais pas 80
donc à partir du moment où les gens qui
ont des fonctions dans les corps
intermédiaires sont imprégnées du
problème et décide de s'en occuper sa
infuse par construction surtout les gens
dont ils ont la charge et par ailleurs
sa infuse aussi par construction sur les
gens qui sont à l'étagé au dessus c'est
à dire leur patron ou éventuellement le
corps politique donc
et ces gens là sortent des
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle on
s'y est attaqué en premier au shift
project alors c'est clair que ça va
passer ou non ça va pas assez vite dans
la réforme des programmes ces gens là
devraient déjà être en train de
travailler jour et nuit à la façon dont
ils vont faire de la place à ce qu'ils
enseignent aujourd'hui pour faire de la
cour pour être capable d'enseigner des
enjeux et si je donne des ordres de
grandeur pour commencer à comprendre de
quoi il retourne il faut 20 heures dans
l'enseignement supérieur pour être
capable de gérer un morceau du problème
il en faut plutôt 50 dans le monde
économique pour les gens déjà en place
pour être capable de comprendre qu'on a
un vrai problème il faut 5 heures et
pour être capable de commencer à gérer
il en faut trentes attend toujours pour
donner des ordres de grandeur donc le
donc c'est dans l'enseignement supérieur
qu'il faut commencer et par ailleurs
c'est de l'enseignement supérieur que
sortent les gens qui seront enseignante
tout court donc donc les gens qui vont
commencer à faire pression aussi pour la
réforme des programmes dans
l'enseignement ce taux courts et
l'enseignement secondaire ils sortiront
aussi pour partie de l'enseignement
supérieur des iufm et ponctuellement
voyeur donc c'était pour ça qu'on a
commencé après bien évidemment il faut
s'occuper de la réforme des programmes
dans le secondaire alors là aussi il ya
quelque chose de difficile c'est qu'il
faut commencer par enseigner les faits
donc il faut pas enseigner du
développement durable le développement
durable c'est de la politique c'est des
intentions c'est des souhaits c'est
éventuellement de la morale tout ça
c'est éminemment respectable mais c'est
pas par ça qu'il faut commencer il faut
commencer par enseigner les faits
donc dans l'enseignement supérieur il
est aussi essentiel de faire comprendre
de quoi on parle quand on parle d'un
climat alors ça en fait en géographie de
poids on parle quand on parle de
changement climatique de quoi on parle
quand on parle de l'énergie c'est à dire
du rôle des machines c'est pas très
compliqué à faire comprendre même un
gamin de 10 ans pour comprendre que
l'énergie c'est une machine
tout ça doit être enseignée et doit être
enseignée dare-dare pour qu'on ait une
petite chance d'avoir une société plus
éclairés qui soit capable de s'attaquer
mieux à la question le début de la
digression que j'ai eu tout à l'heure
sur la convention citoyenne
il est évident que si tout le monde
était passé par les 30 heures que
j'évoque pour comprendre de quel
problème car tourner cette convention
citoyenne aurait beaucoup plus de chance
de produire des mesures qui sont déjà un
peu mieux irakisée articulé fondé etc
c'est évident parce que du coup il
aurait économisé tout le temps qu'ils
ont dû consacrer à comprendre le
problème et à l'évidence leur
compréhension du problème sera toujours
limité par le nombre de gens à qu'ils
ont pu parler et la légitimité soit dit
en passant des gens que on leur a mis
sous des employés
donc il ya voilà donc il ya un énorme
sujet enseignement et c'est c1
qu'est ce que je veux dire c'est un
c'est quelque chose sur lequel
aujourd'hui il faut il faut aller
beaucoup plus vite à l'évidence que ce
qui est fait voilà une fois que j'ai dit
ça j'ai pas de martingale malheur ça à
part vous dire qu'il faut commencer par
l'enseignement par l'enseignement
supérieur alors mon pot main après il ya
tout un truc sur taxe carbone taxe
carbone bienvenue vous en parler de la
taxe carbone définir par sa vu leur taxe
carbone actions individuelles
vous parlez aussi d'actions
individuelles et rats questions
personnelles
accepteriez vous de venir faire une
conférence tout public dans une petite
ville de province
oui puisque j'ai déjà fait la réponse
après la question c'est est ce que je
peux faire ça dans toutes les petites
villes de province n'ont aidé à beaucoup
trop vu le nombre de nuits dont je
dispose
j'ai été ya pas très longtemps à loudun
7000 habitants je sais pas si c'est
petit à petit j'ai été il n'ya pas très
longtemps à part le duc
quatorze mille habitants donc oui j'ai
été à ploërmel il ya de nombreuses
années par combien d'habitants fait pour
les rebelles mais à mon avis c'est pas
beaucoup non plus donc oui je suis en
fait l'essentiel de mes conférences pour
ne rien vous cacher ont lieu en province
je sais j'ai pas regardé le décompte
précis mais l'essentiel sont en province
alors pour les établissements
d'enseignement c'est essentiellement en
province et en ce qui concerne le monde
économique je veux dire que ce
probablement une sur deux qui se passe
en province je fais essentiellement en
province après j'ai un tout petit
problème avec la lumière de minuit je
sais pas si je dois prendre ça comme une
bonne et une mauvaise nouvelle
je dois recevoir en ce moment 5
sollicitation par jour quelque chose
dans ces environnements 9 3 4
oui c'est entre 3 et 5 alors c'est très
simple entre 3 et 5 par jour sur cinq
jours ouvrés ça fait donc entre 15 et 25
par semaine et sachant que je peux dire
oui pour deux bas loyer ça veut dire que
je suis obligé de dire non neuf fois sur
dix quand on fait une demande voilà
c'est ça mon problème
mais à part ça je n'ai pas d'objection
de principe à faire ça après j'ai eu un
problème sur les interventions c'est que
quand je fais les interventions tout
public je remarque que malheureusement
le prenez pas mal viennent
essentiellement dans la salle des gens
qui m'ont déjà vu ou entendu alors que
ce qui m'intéresserait c'est que ce soit
les gens qui viennent donc j'ai un
et puis ça me pose un problème
d'ajustement parce que je ne sais pas si
je dois repartir du début de l'histoire
et donc faire une conf la sic parce que
il en subsiste 10% dans la salle
corrompt pas entendu le début de
l'histoire comme si l'entente de la
suite ou bien si je dois complètement
zappé ça parce que je dois passer partir
du principe que ils ont tous vu ou
entendu lorsque sur une vidéo et donc on
va directement aux questions ou bien on
va directement à des choses qui sont
beaucoup plus appliquée voilà donc pour
le moment je continue à rentrer par le
début de l'histoire est peut-être qu'à
la limite c'est juste complètement à
côté de la plaque
et il faudrait rentrer directement par
des choses qui sont beaucoup plus
appliqué action personnelle alors action
personnelle et dans les pme
en ce qui concerne la queue
personnel certains d'entre vous ont
peut-être vu qu'on va relancer à carbone
cap le bilan carbone personnel donc ça
c'est un projet sur lequel on travaille
maintenant depuis six mois parce que on
a constaté que le fait d'être capable de
parler de l'action personnelle juste
après une formation en entreprise sur le
défi à relever
soulagés les gens dit autrement quand
dans une entreprise on fait le grand
coup de peinture là on va tous mourir
il ya un certain nombre de qui sortent
complètement abattu et ça c'est aussi en
lien avec un truc qu'on est en train de
développer un quart 24 qui s'appelle
déco psychologie certains d'entre vous
on en croit vraiment entendu parler
aussi qui et comment vivre avec ce truc
dans lequel une fois qu'on est rentré on
a beaucoup de mal à sortir yadir
j'oublie et maintenant je m'occupe
d'autres choses et qui est fait de
penser qu'ils sont pas toutes très très
rassurante et donc on a constaté que
quand juste après une intervention on
pouvait avancer et commencer à
travailler sur bilan carbone personnel
ça crée un ballon d'oxygène parce que
les gens se disaient oh mais on peut
quand même faire quelque chose juste à
dire une intervention en entreprise
en général on n'a pas la martingale pour
l'entreprise à laquelle on vient de
s'adresser
il ya une raison assez simple à cela
c'est que selon qu'on fait
l'intervention dans une entreprise qui
met des petits pois en boîte qui fait
des sacs à main ou qui fabrique des
avions
il est évident que les marges de
manoeuvre derrière les choses qu'il faut
commencer à regarder qu'il faut
impliquer ses terrasses sont pas du tout
les mêmes
donc on ne va pas pouvoir juste derrière
une intervention de l'entreprise dire
y'a qu'à faut qu'on fait ça par contre
en ce qui concerne les individus comme
c'est un problème on va donc nous avons
tous les mêmes déterminants de notre
consommation on habite quelque part on
se déplace on mange on achète des trucs
et des bidules on profite d'autres trucs
et d'autres bidules sans les acheter
soit dit en passant on profite de
service public donc on a tous des choses
qui sont très similaires par en quantité
qu'en qualité
mais en fonctionnalités
et donc on peut d'entrée de jeu allait
derrière une intervention sur le bilan
carbone personnel parce qu'on sait que
tout le monde va la voir avec les mêmes
composants donc on a démarré ce projet
qui va commencer à déboucher dans le
courant de l'année prochaine alors pour
moment on a une maquette on a un proto
etc et ce truc là va devenir une
activité à part entière et dont on
espère qu'elle va significativement
contribué à ce besoin de se mettre dans
l'action quand un certain nombre de gens
il ya un sondage qui l'a beaucoup
frappée qui a été publié il ya pas très
longtemps par ipsos le sondage a été
commandé par edf et on demandait aux
gens est ce que vous avez une bonne idée
de ce qu'il faut faire alors je trouve
ça très intéressant de comparer la
question qui est est ce que vous avez
une bonne idée de ce qu'ils ont fait
avec une autre question qui est posée
aux gens au même moment qui est est ce
que vous faites des trucs là si on n'a
pas une bonne idée de ce qu'il faut
faire on veut pas dire que ce qu'on fait
d'utile bon voilà donc les deux réponses
sont pas du tout cohérente évidemment
sinon ça serait pas drôle mais on a une
en france une opinion publique qui se
considère dans les trente pays
interrogés comme étant dans le plus bas
niveau de compréhension de ce qu'il faut
faire alors c'est assez intéressant
parce que par ailleurs on est dans un
des pays qui se pense être dans les plus
en avance sur le discours public sur ce
sujet et donc c'est assez intéressant de
voir que quand même les gens sont assez
perdu ils n'ont pas nécessairement une
très bonne idée ils sont pas les ordres
de grandeur en tête les médias les aide
pas la récente émission sur le sujet qui
a eu à france2 mélanger des trucs qui
valait 1 et des trucs qui valait mille
et des trucs qu'ils n'avaient rien à
voir soit dit en passant
avec le climat donc c'est c'est très
difficile pour les gens de voir une
bonne idée d ordre de grandeur
même pour une partie des gens qui
s'intéressent au sujet et donc voilà
donc on espère qu'avec ce projet là on
va être capable d'amener pierre à
l'édifice
là dessus derrière la compréhension des
enjeux qui est toujours un moment pas
sympathique a passé parce que il faut se
plonger dans la compréhension de quelque
chose qui n'est pas spécialement porter
globalement de bonnes nouvelles donc ça
c'est l'action individuelle
l'action dans les pme j'ai envie de dire
rien n'empêche un patron de pme de faire
exactement quelque part la même chose
c'est-à-dire de se passer à la loupe et
par ailleurs de former ses
collaborateurs qui comprennent quel est
l'objet du quel est l'objet du débat
c'est clair que c'est plus facile dans
des pme qui en la maîtrise de leur
destin donc quand vous êtes sous
traitants de l'automobile que vous avez
un carnet de commandes à trois mois et
que vous fabriquer d'autres produits
vous avez absolument pas le choix a dit
votre client ne veut plus
d'implantations ni de rien savoir que
vous avez de la merde qui va vous tomber
dessus en plus fils pour une autre
raison que votre quotidien vous avez pas
spécialement envie donc le c'est plus
facile de faire rentrer ça dans des pme
qui sont plus maîtresses de leur destin
que des pme qui sont totalement pieds et
poings liés à ingrandes d'antan comme
sous traitants mais vous avez tout un
tas de pme dans lesquelles il est
parfaitement possible de faire entrer
cette préoccupation il n'y a pas de
sujet il n'y a pas de l'objection est là
aussi quelque chose qui peut être
intéressant à noter c'est que dans les
sollicitations spontanée qui ont scellé
par le maître donc dispose a évidemment
qui arrive tu en as carbone 4 cos shift
on voit arriver aujourd'hui des pme
alors dans les deux cas de figure à
carbone 4 on voit arriver des gens de
qui ne posent des questions qui avant
était du ressort des grands groupes
je voudrais m'intéresser à ma stratégie
mon match a montré qu emma bidule on
voit les sein d'entités qui font 50
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
et aux chiffres on voit arriver des
donateurs qui nous dit spontanément
tiens on voudrait vous donner un peu
d'argent alors changé c'est très
intéressant je trouve de commencer à
voir arriver ces deux catégories
d'acteurs dans la danse encore une fois
il n'a pas beaucoup pour le moment
comparé au nombre de pme mais voilà
c'est en train de suer en train de
bouger
et donc la question de la taxe carbone
pour filière faut-il faire la taxe
carbone en 2006 j'ai sorti avec mon
associé et complice alain grandjean un
livre qui s'appelait le plein s'il vous
plaît et qui était une déclaration
d'amour à la taxe carbone
je n'ai fondamentalement pas changé
d'avis au sens de il faut quelque chose
qui ressemble à une contrainte pour que
les gens changent de comportement mais
depuis j'ai enrichi ce raisonnement d'un
certain nombre d'éléments
d'abord la contrainte n'est pas
nécessairement une contrainte en prix la
contrainte et c'est souvent beaucoup
plus efficace de procéder de cette
manière peut être une contrainte
réglementaire une contrainte de
normalisation une interdiction qui est
une variante de la contrainte
réglementaire ou une obligation de faire
essart boucle soit dit en passant avec
d'autres questions qui avaient été posés
sur site et les cinq mesures politiques
que vous estimez prioritaire je vais
donner un exemple sur le chauffage vous
pouvez très bien dire garde-à-vous toute
maison et qui peuvent se souvent des
maisons équipées d'un chauffage au fuel
aura l'interdiction de conserver ce
chauffage au fuel à partir de 2028
voilà vous pouvez très bien le dire ça
c'est une mesure réglementaire donc ce
n'est pas une mesure en prix c'est une
mesure réglementaire ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que tout le monde peut
planifier le changement de sa chaudière
à fuel d'ici à 2028 et ça veut dire que
vous pouvez très bien doubler cette
obligation d'une mesure de type
subventions qui permettent sous
conditions de ressources
évidemment parce que il est hors de
question de payer ça un cadre supérieur
lui il a juste l'obligation exactement
comme il a l'obligation d'enlever sa
bagnole au contrôle technique donc sous
conditions de ressources vous en payer
une partie ou la totalité aux gens qui
ont pas les moyens de se payer eux mêmes
au moment où l'obligation leur tombe
dessus
si vous devez piloter ce changement par
une taxe carbone
il faut donc que vous disiez le prix du
carbone va augmenter jusqu'au moment où
le prix du fuel deviendra insupportable
à ce moment les gens diront il faut que
je change ma chaudière à fuel vous
auriez absolument rien prévu
pour les aider à changer vous pouvez
quand même faire la subvention ok mais
vous voyez bien que vous êtes dans un
système dans lequel la contrainte arrive
de manière j'ai envie de dire
progressive et donc la contrainte
progressive est un truc que les gens
n'aiment pas bien il préfère c'est comme
ça
les contraintes qui leur arrive je suis
plutôt un peu franches on n'a pas dit au
moment où on a dit qu'on allait
interdire de fumer dans les lieux
publics d'abord on aura le droit de
fumer une cigarette par jour dans les
cinq cigarettes par jour dans les lieux
publics puis quatre puis trois puis deux
puis un petit 0 or on n'a pas mis une
taxe sur la cigarette
en dix ans on a aussi monté prix des
cigarettes mais si on attend d'un moment
d'inattention de sa donc la
réglementation est quelque chose qui
crée soit dit en passant un prix
implicite du carbone puisque ça veut
dire que elle donne une valeur mais qui
a une valeur qui est en fait ce qu'il
faut payer pour le remplacer ce carbone
c'est ça la valeur exprimée mais on peut
très bien créer un prix implicite par
une réglementation le système de quotas
ainsi le marché vraiment sur le marché
européen c'est à dire s'il y avait
vraiment une baisse en volume
significative est aussi un système
réglementaire qui pourrait fonctionner
le problème c'est que la baisse en
volume les très compliqué à faire sans
un prix associés parce que si vous ne
fait qu une baisse en volume et qu'il
n'y a pas un prix prévisible à ce moment
où l'industriel n'est pas capable de
faire ses calculs de retour sur
investissement dans ce qui lui permet
d'éviter dé m donc il ne fait rien et le
jour où il n'a rien fait il va voir les
pouvoirs publics en disant ah bah j'ai
rien fait donc si maintenant vous mettez
une contrainte que je suis pas capable
de tenir cracher des localités donc
c'est un système qui ne marche pas bien
s'il n'y a pas un prix associés est un
système mixte
un autre exemple de réglementation et ça
fait partie des choses qui me semble à
l'évidence totalement prioritaires
puisqu'on avait fait une des neuf
mesures du ce que je viens de dire sur
les pompes à chaleur pour moi celui de
mes mesures politiques prioritaires dans
un pays comme la france s'est éjecté le
fioul de chauffage le plus vite possible
pour le remplacer par des pompes à
chaleur supprimer le soutien à l'éolien
et au solaire ce qui va nous faire
économiser quelques dizaines de
milliards d'euros à l'avenir on arrête
tout et on reconvertit les installateurs
de panneaux
c'est à peu près les mêmes c'est des
électriciens et des installateurs
d'éoliennes en installateurs de pompes à
chaleur et avec l'argent on avait prévu
de dépenser les éoliennes et les
panneaux solaires on dépense à dans les
pompes à chaleur pour éjecter de fioul
de chauffage
voilà plan qui est à la fois un plan
réglementaire et un plan industriel qui
ne pose pas de problème majeur pour être
mis en place et ce plan là n'a pas
besoin d'un signal prix sur le carbone
autre exemple qui est la voiture avant
de déployer la voiture électrique il ya
un truc qui est beaucoup plus simple et
beaucoup plus rapide et qui économise
beaucoup plus vite plein de pétrole qui
est de normaliser à la baisse la
consommation des véhicules qu'on vend
donc ce que vous dites c'est en groupe
les véhicules que vous vendez c'est le
système européen actuel sauf qu'il faut
le durcir actuellement il va pas assez
vite
le système européen actuel et il faut
limiter la consommation des véhicules
neufs vendus très rapidement et de
manière féroce il faut doubler ça pour
les véhicules actuellement en
circulation de retour de la vignette
c'est à dire d'une taxe annuelle à la
détention qui est d'autant plus élevé
que le véhicule est puissant et il faut
assurer la transition vers des véhicules
faiblement consommateurs et à faible
vignette pour les gens qui sont de type
gilet jaune c'est à dire des gens qui
ont un besoin domicile travail important
des revenus faibles suffit d'avoir des
revenus faibles en général le besoin
domicile travail et rend malheureusement
en tout cas dès que vous n'êtes pas en
coeur de ville
donc le si vous faites un truc comme ça
vous avez un signal prix mais qui n'est
pas un signal prix sur le carbone qui
est un signal prix sur la détention d'un
véhicule
vous avez une mesure réglementaire qui
s'applique aux constructeurs avec
éventuellement des pénalités c'est pas
ainsi dire prix sur le carbone
c'est une pénalité qui s'applique aux
constructeurs et si vous faites ça vous
voyez que vous faites avancer très vite
la question de la baisse de la
consommation des véhicules neufs vendus
en ce qui concerne le gaz dont plus de
la moitié est utilisé dans le chauffage
ado vous n'avez pas besoin d'une taxe
carbone vous avez de nouveau besoin
d'une substitution par des pompes à
chaleur et d'un système réglementaire
si vous regardez alors le domaine dans
lequel le prix du carbone est vraiment
un domaine dans lequel il a des effets
c'est le domaine industriel
donc en fait le prix du carbone le sol
domaine dans lequel c'est vraiment utile
d'en avoir un c'est le domaine
industriel pourquoi parce que le ménage
est un est une entité qui gère son
économie à courte vue qui anticipe très
peu qui ne fait pas de business plan qui
n'embauchent pas des crânes d'oeuf pour
manipuler de l'excellent toute la
journée on ne fait pas ça dans mon
ménage
déjà quand on a une gestion un peu près
correct de sa trésorerie personnelle
c'est le bout du monde
donc on ne fait pas ça par contre dans
une entreprise on fait ça on embauche
des tas de gens qui sont en train de
m'écouter là pour aller faire du
business plan des plans de trésorerie
des tableurs excel compliqué beaucoup
trop parfois dur est pour regarder à
quoi peut ressembler l'avenir
donc c'est des endroits dans lesquels on
détecte très bien les signaux faibles
liés à des variations de prix et pour
autant que ces variations de prix puisse
être anticipée on va mettre en oeuvre du
jus de cerveau pour être capable d'y de
comment dire d'y apporter une réponse
optimale
donc dans une entreprise en particulier
une grande entreprise
on est parfaitement capable de payer
quelques personnes pour faire des pas de
calculs dans tous les coins pour savoir
quelle est la meilleure manière de
répondre à un prix du carbone qui
augmente ce qui veut dire que le seul
domaine dans lequel s'est vraiment
pertinent de mettre en place une taxe
carbone à mon sens c'est dans le domaine
des entreprises
on peut prendre un exemple la grande
bretagne avait une taxe sur la
production électrique applicables aux
producteurs d'électricité donc c'est une
taxe carbone applicable aux entreprises
parce qu'elle a considéré que le système
des quotas qui s'applique aussi aux
producteurs d'électricité matérialisait
pas un prix suffisamment élevé et
surtout suffisamment prévisible pour que
ces gens là fassent des efforts ça a
contribué à la diminution très rapide du
charbon dans la production électrique en
grande bretagne donc c'est un système
qui peut fonctionner alors il fonctionne
d'autant plus facilement qu'il ya des
alternatives qui sont pas très très loin
en terme de rentabilité technique
économique
c'est absolument évident mais c'est un
système qui fonctionne très très bien
si vous augmenter de manière
significative le prix du co2 et que vous
dites
comme c'est le cas dans la mer du nord à
statoil a si vous m'en fous hissé de co2
je vous fais pas payer la pénalité
vous allez avoir un certain nombre
d'acteurs qui vont s'intéresser aux car
votre capture et au soir yussois storage
donc vous avez besoin dans le monde
industriel d'augmenter le prix du co2 ça
c'est absolument certain
et par ailleurs vous avez besoin de le
faire de manière prévisible parce que si
vous ne le faites pas de manière
prévisible mais hiératique on sait pas
quoi dire aux jeunes crâne d'oeuf sortie
d'école que je ne nommerai pas quelle
est la valeur on sait pas quelle est
leur dire quelle est la valeur qu'il
faut mettre dans le business plan sur le
futur prix du carbone du coup on ne sait
pas faire des calculs de retour sur
investissement du coup j'en reviens à ce
que je disais on ne fait rien et du coup
après une fois qu'on a rien fait on fait
du chantage
ce qu'on veut pour dire que c'était pas
la peine enfin pour dire qu'il faut
surtout pas augmenter les efforts et
d'essai faire les initiatives
volontaires donc dans le domaine de
l'entreprise
m un prix explicite est quelque chose
qui est intéressant parce que par
ailleurs autant chez les ménages les
usages sont très standardisé tout le
monde conduit une voiture il ya 37
million de voitures dans ce pays donc
normaliser la consommation des voitures
et compenser sa part un impôt à la
détention pour pas qu'on soit tenté de
se rabattre sur la hausse de la masse de
la voiture ce qu'on a fait depuis des
décennies quand son efficacité augmente
c'est un système qui très simple qui
s'applique à tous les ménages sur
l'organe de chauffage du bâtiment c'est
un système qui est très simple qui
s'applique à tous les ménages
par contre dans l'activité industrielle
enfin dans l'activité économique
vous avez 60 secteur 250 sous secteur et
donc prévoir d'en haut
quelles sont les mesures réglementaires
qui doivent s'appliquer à chaque sous
secteur pour qu'il aille dans la bonne
direction c'est juste un travail de
titan donc c'est pour ça que un système
assez libérale de type taxe carbone dans
le monde de l'entreprise ou du coup les
entreprises vont répondre en optimisant
chacune de leur côté est un système qui
n'est pas idiot alors si je vais
jusqu'au bout du raisonnement on dira
oui mais même un système comme ça va
faire de la casse et je dis ouais ok
contact et ben ça fera de la casse
et je vais finir sur cette conclusion
très sympathique on considère
aujourd'hui que il est parfaitement
légitime qu'une société allait au tapis
c'est à dire à la barre du tribunal
c'est à dire fasse faillite parce
qu'elle n'est pas capable de contribuer
à l'effort collectif en ce qui concerne
l'éducation la santé ou les retraites
cet appel ces charges sociales
donc on considère que la santé ligue
retraite et accessoirement un certain
nombre d'autres types
vie du pays que si une entreprise n'a
pas les moyens d'y contribuer c'est à
dire n'a pas les moyens de payer les
charges salaires
eh bien elle fait faillite et c'est la
vie eh bien je considère personnellement
que le jeu du changement climatique est
tellement important que si une
entreprise n'a pas les moyens de
contribuer à l'effort collectif en étant
capable de s'adapter à un prix du
carbone qui augmente elle fera faillite
c'est la vie et c'est sa contribution à
l'effort collectif et la seule question
qui se pose c'est exactement comme pour
les entreprises qui font faillite parce
qu'elles n'ont pas les moyens de payer
leurs charges
comment est-ce qu'on s'assure dans un
contexte de stabilité sociale que les
perdantes d'affaires c'est-à-dire les
salariés derrière retrouveront un emploi
sans trop tarder voilà et mais il ne
faut pas avoir peur de dire que le
système voilà ils pourront revenir au
début de juste pour donner un exemple
pour en revenir au début de cette
discussion
il me semble que cet effort là c'est à
dire accepter des entreprises aillent au
tapis quand elles sont pas capables de
prendre leur part à l'effort collectif
sur la baisse des émissions et quelque
chose comme exactement comme il y en a
aujourd'hui qui font faillite encore une
fois parce qu'elles peuvent pas payer
leurs charges sociales ou pas payer
leurs fournisseurs considère pas que
voilà c'est pas grave
clip les fournisseurs non et bien c'est
il me semble que ces atouts prend un
inconvénient qui est considérablement
moins d élever que l'inconvénient
d'aller à l'effondrement écosystémiques
énergétiques climatiques et aux gentils
chaos qui s'ensuivra derrière et qui
fera beaucoup plus douleur que
simplement le fait d'avoir à changer
d'emploi parce que sa boîte a fait
faillite parce qu'elle n'était pas
capable d'assumer sa contribution à
l'effort national
voilà donc ça sera ça le mot de la fin
la taxe carbone pour les entreprises
c'est une très bonne idée et il faut pas
avoir peur de son ombre dans cette
affaire
il est évident qu'une transition
ça secoue ce qu'il faut c'est être
capable de traiter les perdants être
capable d'avoir cours eu du temps de
l'empathie et l'envi
de faire en sorte qu'il retrouve quelque
chose à faire mais il faut pas se dire
que si on abîme une seule entreprise
avec la taxe carbone on n'y va pas parce
que si on a ce genre de raisonnement on
n'ira jamais dû le par ailleurs que là
où le hasard nous emmènera et il est
fort probable qu'ils décident moins bien
que nous comme disaient les dessins
animés de tex avery date soul folk ce
merci d'avoir suivi tout ou partie de
cette petite discussion non pas au coin
du feu puisque savez que c'est interdit
presque maintenant en ile-de-france au
coin de l'ordinateur bonne fin de soirée
et à bientôt
au revoir tout le monde